I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Angela Kinsey. Jenna Fisher. I think I have a meta moment. Because today. Yeah. In the world. Yeah. The 100th episode of Office, ladies, podcast came out. Yes. And now here we are recording our podcast about the 100th episode of The Office. That's very meta. And our ages almost equal 100. Oh, well, why do you have to throw that in there? I don't
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您独家制作《办公室》的重温播客《办公室女士》。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。安吉拉·金西。詹娜·费舍尔。我想我有一个元时刻。因为今天。是的。在这个世界上。是的。办公室女士播客的第100期节目发布了。是的。现在我们在这里录制关于《办公室》第100集的播客。这非常元。而且我们的年龄加起来差不多100岁。哦，好吧，你为什么要把这个扯进来？我不知道
know. I was looking for more hundreds. All right. Well, we should get into this episode. We have so much to cover. We do. This is going to be a long one. That's what she said. She said. It's Company Picnic, season five, episode 28, written by Jen Salata and Pauline Burstein, directed by the dearest man on the planet, Ken Quapas. Summary, it's the Dunder Mifflin Company Picnic. All of them are there. All the branches. Yes. In their own special t-shirts that have their branch name on them. Oh, I have it, lady. We'll get to it. Well, the Scranton branch is going to compete against the other branches in a company-wide volleyball tournament. Meanwhile, Michael and Holly reunite to perform a comedy skit where they accidentally
我只是在找更多的一百。好吧，我们应该进入这一集了。我们要讲的内容太多了。确实如此。这一集会很长。她也这么说过。她说。这就是公司野餐，第五季第二季，第28集，由简·萨拉塔和保利·伯斯坦编剧，由地球上最亲爱的男人肯·夸帕斯执导。剧情梗概，这是邓德米夫林公司的公司野餐。他们都在那里。所有分公司。是的。穿着印有他们分公司名字的专属T恤。哦，我有，女士。我们等会儿会讲到。斯克兰顿分公司将在全公司范围内的排球锦标赛中与其他分公司竞争。与此同时，迈克尔和霍利重聚，表演了一出喜剧短剧，他们不小心
reveal some confidential information to the crowd. David Wallace, why would you tell Michael Scott anything of that magnitude and expect him to keep it quiet? When David introduces their skit, one of my favorite lines is when he says, I have not seen this. I have not seen this. Yeah. Finally, Dwight is going to defend Angela's honor. Till Rolf. Yeah. Yeah. And ultimately, an ankle injury is going to send Pam to the hospital where she and Jim get some surprising news. So sweet. I love this episode. Fast fact number one, Company Picnic was the 100th episode of The Office. Yes. This was a very big deal for the network because it meant our show was now eligible for syndication. Which I didn't even know
向人群透露了一些机密信息。大卫·华莱士，你为什么会把这种量级的任何事情告诉迈克尔·斯科特并指望他能保密呢？当大卫介绍他们的短剧时，我最喜欢的台词之一就是他说，我还没看过这个。我还没看过这个。是的。最后，德怀特将捍卫安吉拉的荣誉。去找罗尔夫。是的。是的。最终，脚踝受伤将把帕姆送往医院，在那里她和吉姆得到了一些令人惊讶的消息。太甜了。我很喜欢这一集。趣味事实一，《公司野餐》是《办公室》的第100集。是的。这对电视台来说是一件大事，因为这意味着我们的节目现在有资格进行辛迪加播出了。而我甚至不知道
what that meant. I thought maybe we should explain it. Okay, do. Because I remember when we hit 100, I was like, what's all the hullabaloo? Yeah, sure. We hit 100. That's cool. I know. We'll go out to dinner or something. No. No. For the network, super big. They all showed up to the set. They did. They brought a cake. It was as big as a poker table. It was humongous. It was. That's what she said. That's what she said. They brought champagne. But we couldn't drink it. No, because we had to go back to work. We actually only had 15 minutes with the cake all said and told. It was on our lunch break. So if you wanted to eat, we had 30 minutes photo with the cake and then we had to run out the door. Well, I remember
那是什么意思。我想也许我们应该解释一下。好吧，解释吧。因为我记得当我们达到100集时，我是这样想的，有什么好大惊小怪的？是的，当然。我们达到了100。挺酷的。我知道。我们会出去吃晚饭什么的。不。不。对电视台来说，超级大。他们都来到了片场。他们确实来了。他们带了一个蛋糕。它有一个扑克桌那么大。它巨大无比。确实如此。她也这么说过。她也这么说过。他们带来了香槟。但我们不能喝。不，因为我们要回去工作。算上所有时间，我们实际上只有15分钟的时间吃蛋糕。那是在我们的午休时间。所以如果你想吃，我们有30分钟的时间和蛋糕合影，然后我们就得夺门而出。嗯，我记得
Greg gave a very nice speech. He did. About what the 100 episodes had meant to him. Entertainment tonight was there. All the press was there. I mean, this was a super big deal. Let's tell you why. When a show hits 100 episodes and goes into syndication, it means that the network can now start selling the show in a package to different places where they can rerun it. So it doesn't just run on NBC anymore. It gets on all the cable networks. Like Comedy Central, how it reruns on Comedy Central. Right. And guys, remember, this predates all streaming. Yes. So this was all kind of a cable thing. But this meant big money for the network. I didn't know that, but it makes sense because these other places pay them
格雷格发表了一场非常精彩的演讲。他确实讲了。关于这100集对他的意义。《今夜娱乐》也在场。所有的媒体都在场。我是说，这真的是一件超级大事。让我们告诉你为什么。当一部剧达到100集并进入辛迪加播放在线重播时，这意味着电视台现在可以开始将该剧打包出售给不同的地方进行重播。所以它不再只在NBC播出了。它会在所有的有线电视台播出。就像喜剧中心频道，它如何在喜剧中心频道重播。没错。大家记住，这发生在所有流媒体出现之前。是的。所以这在某种程度上全是有线电视的事情。但这给电视台带来了巨额资金。我以前不知道，但这就说得通了，因为这些其他地方会付钱给他们
to have it. Yes. But what I think a lot of people don't know is that the actors do not cash in on this unless they are what is called profit participants. Oh yeah. And guess what? We weren't. We were not. Now our union SAG does negotiate a small fee for syndicated reruns. So it's very fun. You get checks and they're great. They're great, but they have you guys this like cascading tier. So you get a check and you're like, whoop, whoop. Then the next one's a little lower, then it's a little lower, then it's a little lower, then it's a little lower, and then it's for like $2. Well, you know that bar that they have called residuals in Burbank? Yes. This is a famous bar, you guys. Yeah. So there's this bar called residuals.
来拥有它。是的。但我想很多人不知道的是，演员们并不能从中分一杯羹，除非他们是所谓的利润参与者。哦，是的。你猜怎么着？我们不是。我们不是。现在我们的工会SAG确实为辛迪加重播谈判了一笔小额费用。所以这很有趣。你会收到支票，而且很棒。它们很棒，但它们有一个像阶梯式层级的东西。所以你收到一张支票，你会想，哇，哇。然后下一张低一点，然后低一点，然后低一点，然后低一点，最后大概只有2美元。好吧，你知道他们在伯班克设有的那个叫做“残余金”的酒吧吗？是的。这是一个著名的酒吧，伙计们。是的。所以有这么一个酒吧叫残余金。
And if you're an actor and you bring in a residual check that's under a dollar, they'll give you a free drink and then they tack your check up on the wall. Yeah. I have a friend of mine who saved a residual check for, I think it was 17 cents. And I put it on his bulletin board. Lady, I got one for 21 cents. It costs more money to mail it to me, probably and to print it. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So yeah, they were able to make a lot of money selling the show to cable. And then eventually you guys, I mean, you know, they were able to sell it to all the streamers. Yeah. I guess we should probably say the actors don't get a big payout for that either. That money goes to the profit participants. See, the word
如果你是一个演员，你拿来一张金额低于一美元的残余金支票，他们会给你一杯免费饮料，然后把你的支票钉在墙上。是的。我有一个朋友，他存了一张残余金支票，我想那是17美分。我把它贴在了他的公告板上。女士，我收到过一张21美分的。寄给我的邮费可能比这还贵，打印费也是。是的。没错。所以是的，他们通过把节目卖给有线电视赚了很多钱。然后最终，伙计们，我的意思是，你知道，他们能够把它卖给所有的流媒体。是的。我想我们大概应该说，演员们为此也没有得到一大笔酬劳。这笔钱归了利润参与者。你看，利润参与者这个词
profit participant is something I had never heard of. And as it turns out, if you're one of those folks, that is Lushataki. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. It sure is. Angela, you found out the inspiration for our hundredth episode while listening to the DVD commentary. Will you share? I will. I'm officially part of Fast Facts number one, folks. Oh, yeah. Here's the thing. If you love really good DVD commentaries, this is one not to miss of the office box set because Ken Coapas and Paul Lieberstein and Jen Salata share so many great details. They are the only three people on this commentary. And I really enjoyed it. Paul shared that the idea for the company picnic, they had it at the very beginning of season five. They
是我从未听说过的。事实证明，如果你是其中一员，那就是发财了。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。确实如此。安吉拉，你在听DVD评论音轨时发现了我们第100集的灵感来源。能分享一下吗？我会的。我正式成为了趣味事实一的一部分，伙计们。哦，是的。事情是这样的。如果你喜欢非常棒的DVD评论音轨，《办公室》套装里的这一集绝对不容错过，因为肯·夸帕斯、保罗·利伯斯坦和简·萨拉塔分享了太多精彩的细节。他们是这个评论音轨里仅有的三个人。我真的很喜欢。保罗分享说，关于公司野餐的想法，他们在第五季刚开始时就有了。他们
always knew that they would be working towards this episode. Wow. And Jen shared that they wanted to bring all of the branches together. They researched company picnics. This delighted me because I just imagined Jen googling company picnics. She was a lady who googled. I was going to say, like, that would have been us. We would have been like, wait, let's research what people do. And one of the things that came up was a volleyball tournament. So they thought that would be fun. And Paul said he thought it was a great way to bring everyone back together, all the different branches, all the different characters for this big one hundredth episode. The only characters you don't see that were in the world of the
一直都知道他们会朝着这一集努力。哇。简分享说，他们想把所有的分公司聚集在一起。他们研究了公司野餐。这让我很高兴，因为我脑海中浮现出简在谷歌上搜索公司野餐的画面。她是一个会用谷歌搜索的女士。我本来想说，就像那会是我们的风格一样。我们会说，等等，让我们研究一下人们都做些什么。其中出现的一项活动是排球锦标赛。所以他们认为这会很有趣。保罗说他认为这是将所有人，所有不同的分公司、所有不同的角色重新聚集在一起参加这个盛大的第一百集的绝佳方式。你在剧中看不到的唯一角色
show really were Jan. But it doesn't make sense for Jan to come back. Yes. And Karen. Yes, we got mail about that. Where was Karen? And Jen Salata did an interview where she said Rashida Jones was filming Parks and Recreation and they couldn't get her for a whole week of work to be at this picnic. And then they realized, wait, she would be on maternity leave. So they tracked her story wise as being on maternity leave. And that's why she wasn't there. Well, that worked out perfect. While the volleyball was a great idea, Ken did share that it was a logistical nightmare because they started filming and they were trying to keep with the rules of volleyball, which
其实就是简。但是简回来并不合理。是的。还有凯伦。是的，我们收到了关于那个的邮件。凯伦在哪里？简·萨拉塔做过一次采访，她说拉什达·琼斯当时在拍摄《公园与游憩》，他们无法让她空出一整周的时间来参加这个野餐。然后他们意识到，等等，她当时在休产假。所以他们在剧情上把她的行踪设定为正在休产假。这就是她不在那里的原因。嗯，这安排得太完美了。虽然排球是个好主意，但肯确实分享说，这是一场后勤噩梦，因为他们开始拍摄时试图遵守排球规则，这意味着
means the teams trade sides depending on score or whatever. But they just had to bail. They had to bail because it just got too complicated. And Jen said she had this memory of looking over at Ken and he had a clipboard and he had little quarter and he was tracing this coin with a pencil and placing it and mapping out where everyone was going to stand and who was serving and who was playing what position because it was so complex to shoot. I thought it was interesting that they chose volleyball. Any company picnic I've ever been to, it's usually softball. But I do see how people are really spread out in softball. So I guess that makes sense to me. But I mean, I can't even imagine.
球队根据比分或其它情况交换场地。但他们不得不放弃。他们不得不放弃，因为事情变得太复杂了。简说她有一个记忆，看到肯拿着一个剪贴板，上面有一个小四分之一硬币，他用铅笔描摹这枚硬币，把它放在那里，规划每个人要站在哪里，谁在发球，谁在打什么位置，因为拍摄太复杂了。我觉得他们选择排球很有趣。我参加过的任何公司野餐，通常都是垒球。但我确实明白在垒球中人们的分布有多开。所以我想这对我来说说得通。不过，我是说，我甚至无法想象。
Jen and Paul shared this other thing. Jen said that her and Paul, as they wrote this episode, they thought that each team had nine players. And so they wrote the whole script with each team having nine players. And then they got to the production meeting. And in the production meeting, someone was like, you know, on volleyball teams, you have six players on the court, not nine. And Paul and them were like, what? But yeah, so they had to change that like immediately. And I have more fun tidbits from the three of them in the commentary I'll sprinkle through the episode. All right, Angela, great job on that Fast Facts.
简和保罗分享了另一件事。简说，她和保罗在写这一集时，以为每个队有九名队员。于是他们写了整个剧本，每个队都有九名队员。然后他们到了制作会议上。在制作会议上，有人说，你知道，在排球队里，场上有六名队员，而不是九名。保罗他们就说，什么？但是，是的，所以他们不得不立即改变这一点。我从他们三人的评论中收集了更多有趣的琐事，我会在这一集里穿插分享。好的，安吉拉，那个趣味事实做得太棒了。
Oh, thank you. Really enjoyed that. Thanks so much. You told me, you were like, Jenna, there's some great stuff about the inspiration behind the episode. And I said, I'm holding a spot for you up in Fast Facts, lady. You did. All right, Fast Facts number two is a location breakdown. Now, the signs hanging in this episode say that this picnic is being held at the Meadows in upstate New York. I could not find
哦，谢谢你。真的很喜欢。非常感谢。你告诉过我，你对我说，詹娜，有一些关于这一集幕后灵感的很棒的料。我说，我为你留了一个位置在趣味事实里，女士。你确实留了。好的，趣味事实二是一个取景地解析。现在，挂在这一集里的标牌上说，这次野餐是在纽约州北部的梅多斯（The Meadows）举行的。我找不到
any information on this or if this is a real place. Faky place. Perhaps. Does anyone know? Please comment on Office Ladies Pod. If you've ever been to a park called the Meadows in upstate New York, I'd love to know. Fan question. Rayon from Pakistan would like to know where did we actually film this episode? Well, we filmed at Calamigos Ranch in Malibu Canyon. It is a beautiful location. It's kind of nestled into the side of this canyon in the Malibu Mountains. Did you know it has its own water source from a spring on the property?
关于这个的任何信息，也不知道这是否是一个真实的地方。虚构的地方。也许吧。有人知道吗？请在《办公室女士》播客上留言。如果你去过纽约州北部一个叫梅多斯（The Meadows）的公园，我很想知道。粉丝提问。来自巴基斯坦的雷扬想知道我们实际上是在哪里拍摄这一集的？嗯，我们在马里布峡谷的卡拉米戈斯牧场（Calamigos Ranch）拍摄的。这是一个美丽的地方。它坐落在马里布山脉这个峡谷的侧面。你知道它有来自物业泉水的自己的水源吗？
I didn't know that, but I know a lot of people get married there. I've been to a wedding there. You know what? Randy Cordray knew about this location because he had been the best man at a wedding there. And when the script came up, he remembered it and suggested it to our locations manager, Kyle Alexander. And they scouted it and they all agreed it was perfect. So now, Angela, you mentioned how Ken Quapas said like this was a logistically difficult shoot. Randy said this was a very difficult episode to pull off logistically from a production
我不知道那个，但我知道很多人在那里结婚。我去那里参加过一场婚礼。你知道吗？兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）知道这个地方，因为他曾是那里一场婚礼的伴郎。当剧本出来时，他记起了这个地方，并把它推荐给了我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大（Kyle Alexander）。他们去实地考察了，并且都一致认为这里完美极了。所以现在，安吉拉，你提到肯·夸帕斯说这像是一次后勤上非常困难的拍摄。兰迪说，从制作的角度来看，这也是一集在后勤上极难完成的剧集
side because we had so many people. So many people and we were in the middle of a canyon. He said we had to hire additional crew, including multiple medics. And we had hydration stations and sunscreen stations and Sergio and Alan, our caterers. They had to triple their staff. They had three lines to serve lunch, like three buffet lines. And then Peter and Vartan at Craft Service, they also had three stations instead of one. It was a lot of concern about being able to feed everybody because all the background food, people were told not to eat. Yeah, it was fakie food. It was real food, but it had been at various temperatures that made it sort of unsafe to
因为我们有太多人了。太多人了，而且我们还在峡谷中间。他说我们不得不聘请额外的剧组人员，包括多名医疗人员。我们有补水站和防晒霜站，还有我们的餐饮供应商塞尔吉奥和阿兰。他们不得不将员工人数增加三倍。他们有三条线来提供午餐，就像三个自助餐线一样。然后是餐饮服务处的彼得和瓦尔坦，他们也设立了三个站而不是一个。大家非常担心能否喂饱所有人，因为所有的背景食物，大家都被告知不要吃。是的，那是假食物。它是真正的食物，但它一直处于各种温度下，这使得它有点不安全
eat. So if you watch the episode, you might notice no one eats anything off of their plates of food. Check it out. Vartan said there was probably like 250 people there. Guess what my fast fact number three is, lady? What? I'll tell you. We had 14 guest actors, our regular cast, and 185 background performers for this episode. Also, I thought this was interesting. Some of the background performers were called special business performers.
所以如果你看这一集，你可能会注意到没有人吃他们盘子里的任何食物。仔细看看。瓦尔坦说那里大概有250人。你猜我的趣味事实三是什么，女士？什么？我来告诉你。我们这一集有14位客串演员，我们的常规演员，以及185位背景表演者。另外，我觉得这很有趣。一些背景表演者被称为特殊业务表演者。
Special business? You know what their special business was? Volleyball? Yeah, playing volleyball for hours on end. Lady, were you ever a background performer? You know it. That's how I earned my SAG card. Yeah.
特殊业务？你知道他们的特殊业务是什么吗？打排球？是的，没完没了地打几个小时排球。女士，你曾经当过背景表演者吗？你当然知道。这就是我如何获得SAG（演员工会）卡的方法。是的。
Same. Did you have any special business listed on your background performer resume? Yes, I did. What was your special business? That I could speak Indonesian. Oh. Mm-hmm. My special business was waterskiing, bowling, and animal handling.
我也是。你的背景表演者简历上列出过任何特殊业务吗？是的，我有。你的特殊业务是什么？我会说印尼语。哦。嗯-hmm。我的特殊业务是滑水、保龄球和动物驯导。
Oh, I also put I could play tennis and roller skate. Yeah. Those are a big deal. Yeah, that's a big deal. I was on 90210. Did you have to do any of your special business? I didn't. I was one of Tori's spelling sorority sisters, but I did pass the ballots of a voting, a sorority voting session, too. I handed them to Tori.
哦，我还写过我会打网球和溜冰。是的。这些可都是大事。是的，这可是大事。我上过《飞越比弗利（90210）》。你必须做你的任何特殊业务吗？我没有。我是托丽的读写联谊会姐妹之一，但我确实也递交了投票的选票，一个联谊会投票环节的选票。我把它们交给了托丽。
Oh, you got to interact. I was a, yes, briefly. I said nothing. I just handed some paper to her. I was an extra on the movie Pleasantville, starring Reese Witherspoon and Toby McGuire, and I had to play a teenager, and that was really fun because I got to dress up in old-timey clothes the whole time, but check this out. They came into the extras-holding area because they needed three couples to make out in the backseat of a car. They were going to pan across all these different couples making out until they got to the car with the lead actors.
哦，你得到了互动。我是一个，是的，简短地。我什么也没说。我只是递了一些纸给她。我是电影《欢乐谷》的群众演员，该片由瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和托比·马奎尔主演，我必须扮演一个青少年，这真的很有趣，因为我全程都得穿着复古的衣服，但你看这个。他们来到群众演员候场区，因为他们需要三对情侣在汽车后座上热吻。他们打算扫过所有这些不同热吻的情侣，直到他们来到主角所在的汽车。
Were you part of the make-out couples? No. You would have become a featured extra if you did it, and you got a bump in pay, but I felt too shy, so I didn't volunteer. But Lady, we had a very special background performer on this episode of The Office, and it was Jenny Tan, who runs the fan website, OfficeTelly.com. Yes. We had all become friends with her, and she was invited to spend the entire week with us getting an exclusive look at the finale, and they asked her to be an extra. And Lady,
你是热吻情侣中的一员吗？不是。如果你做了，你就会成为特约群众演员，片酬也会上涨，但我当时太害羞了，所以我没有自愿报名。但是女士，我们这一集《办公室》有一个非常特别的背景表演者，她就是珍妮·陈（Jenny Tan），她运营着粉丝网站OfficeTelly.com。是的。我们都和她成为了朋友，她被邀请和我们一起度过整整一周，独家探班大结局，他们邀请她当群众演员。而且女士，
she documented all five days of shooting this episode on OfficeTelly.com. It is still there, and she has tons of photos. Amazing. She also gave this amazing breakdown of what it was like to be a background performer on Company Picnic. Oh, my gosh. Are you going to share? Yes. You guys, Jenny was sort of someone who made a community for The Office online before anyone
她记录了拍摄这一集的全部五天过程，并发布在OfficeTelly.com上。它现在还在那里，她有大量的照片。太惊人了。她还对在《公司野餐》中担任背景表演者的感受进行了精彩的剖析。哦，天哪。你要分享吗？是的。伙计们，珍妮可以说是那种在任何人都在做这件事之前，就在网上为《办公室》建立了一个社区的人。
was doing that. Before social media. Before social media, and she was there for the show, providing this community in our earliest days, when we didn't even know the future of the show, and it meant a lot to all of us. And we would reach out to her and give her exclusive tips or content or photos that she would post on the website, and it became kind of the hub. Yeah. And this was before Networks did any kind of social media or website for any of
在社交媒体出现之前。在社交媒体出现之前，她就在那里为这部剧提供支持，在我们的早期，在我们甚至不知道这部剧的未来会怎样的时候，为我们提供这个社区，这对我们所有人意义重大。我们会联系她，给她独家的小贴士、内容或照片，她会发布在网站上，它成为了某种中心。是的。这发生在各大电视台为他们的任何节目建立任何社交媒体或网站之前，
their shows, and our show had this presence because of Jenny. And so her documenting of our show is very extensive, and it's all still there on OfficeTelly.com. There's all these exclusive interviews. It's amazing. She said you could really tell the people who were professional background artists because they would bring tons of gear, like rolling luggage, filled with what she said, quote, outerwear for every possible weather condition, chairs, water, snacks, something to read. It's like, you know, when you go to the beach and you see people, like, come with the wagon
而我们的节目因为珍妮而有了这种存在感。所以她对我们节目的记录非常广泛，而且现在都还留在OfficeTelly.com上。有所有这些独家采访。太棒了。她说你真的能看出谁是专业的背景演员，因为他们会带大量的装备，比如滚动行李箱，里面装满了她所说的，引述，“适合所有可能天气状况的外套、椅子、水、零食、阅读的东西。”这就像，你知道，当你去海滩时，你看到人们，就像，带着小货车来
full of stuff or at the soccer game, that's a professional background performer. Oh, yeah. I remember doing background work, and there was a guy that had a backpack that was a chair. Yes. And you could open the backpack, and there was stuff inside, or you could unfold it and sit in it. Because background performers do not get trailers. You mostly are going to be directed to a holding area with some folding chairs in it, but my
全是道具或者在踢足球，那是一个专业的背景演员。哦，对。我记得我做过背景演员，当时有个家伙背着一个背包，那个背包就是把椅子。是的。你可以打开背包，里面有东西，或者你可以把它展开坐在上面。因为背景演员是没有房车的。你通常会被带到一个放着几把折叠椅的休息区，不过我
experience was there were never enough chairs for each person. Never enough chairs, and they're usually outside. Yeah. So Jenny said that when she first went to the wardrobe tent, she was given an apron to wear, and she said she would be a grill cook. But then about an hour later, production pulled her aside and made her a Buffalo Branch employee, and then they winked and said, you're going to be part of a special branch. But she didn't know what that meant yet.
的经验是，椅子从来都不够每一个人坐。椅子永远不够，而且它们通常在户外。是的。珍妮说，当她第一次去服装帐篷时，她拿到了一条围裙穿，并且她被告知她将扮演一个烧烤厨师。但大约一个小时后，制片组把她拉到一边，让她扮演一个水牛分公司的员工，然后他们眨了眨眼说，你将成为一个特殊分支的一部分。但她当时还不知道那是什么意思。
And get this. Jenny talked to a bunch of the background folks, and she said that most of them were not office fans, that they had never seen the show, and that a few of them did not know who Steve Carell was. She said they were thrilled to be working on our show because we had a reputation for treating background performers very, very well and for providing great food. She said one person told her from a work perspective to be able to be an extra on the office for an entire week, I feel like I won the lottery. So that made me really proud that our show did a good job.
还有这个。珍妮和许多背景演员聊过，她说他们大多数人其实并不是《办公室》的粉丝，他们从来没有看过这部剧，而且其中几个人甚至不知道史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是谁。她说他们很高兴能来我们的剧组工作，因为我们以对待背景演员非常非常好以及提供极好的食物而闻名。她说有人告诉她，从工作的角度来看，能够连续整整一周在《办公室》里当群演，我觉得自己像中了彩票一样。这让我为我们的节目表现出色感到非常自豪。
Because as a person who did a lot of background work, yeah, it meant a lot. Usually the background performers were like the last people who get to go through the lunch line, and it's like what's left almost nothing, and you were not allowed to go to craft services. But on our show, we had a whole buffet set aside just for the background performers and a whole craft services table that they kept full, and it was awesome. Well, you know, that's Randy Cordray. Randy took care of everyone.
因为作为一个做过很多背景工作的人，是的，这意义重大。通常背景演员是排在最后去吃午饭的人，基本上吃剩的几乎什么都没有，而且你是不被允许去剧组餐饮区的。但在我们的剧组，我们专门为背景演员准备了整整一桌自助餐，还有一个一直装满食物的剧组餐饮桌，这太棒了。你知道的，那是兰迪·科德雷。兰迪照顾到了每一个人。
However you were a part of our show, he was going to make sure you were taken care of. That is absolutely true, lady. All right, lady, those are all my fast facts. I mean, it's a lot. Well, it's a huge episode. I know. All right, should we take a break and then start breaking down this episode? Just heads up, it's going to be a long one.
无论你是我们剧组的哪一部分，他都会确保你被照顾得很好。这绝对是真的，女士。好了，女士，这就是我的所有快讯。我是说，这内容真多。嗯，这是一集体量巨大的剧。我知道。好了，我们该休息一下，然后开始拆解这一集吗？提前说一下，这一集会很长。
That's what she said. We are back and the phone is ringing at reception. The lights are out. Yeah. Erin takes the call and she says that Michael is not in right now, but he'll call this person back when he gets back. When he wakes up, I mean gets back. Right.
简而言之。我们回来了，前台的电话正在响。灯都熄了。是的。艾琳接了电话，她说迈克尔现在不在，但他回来后会给这个人回电话。我是说等他醒来，等他回来。对。
Well, guess what? He's not sleeping because he had chicken pot pie for lunch. Not just chicken pot pie, Jenna, he had the whole entire chicken pot pie. A family size. A family size. A chicken pot pie. And he's gone to sleep, as one would do. Well, the whole office is going to prank Michael into thinking that it is five o'clock when
好吧，你猜怎么着？他没在睡觉，因为他午饭吃的是鸡肉锅派。不只是鸡肉锅派，珍娜，他吃了一整盘鸡肉锅派。家庭装的。家庭装的。一个鸡肉锅派。他去睡觉了，正常人都会这样。好吧，整个办公室都要恶作剧整蛊迈克尔，让他以为现在是五点钟，
he wakes up so that they can all go home early. And Dwight does not normally condone leaving early, but he does have that appointment with his horse doctor today, so he's in. Even catch from Marcy G in Connecticut, there is a small detail that tickles me every time I see it. In the cold open, when they're tricking a sleeping Michael into thinking it's 5 p.m., they have to change the time on his watch. Pam has her shoes off so she doesn't make noise in his office.
这样他们就可以提前下班了。德怀特通常不赞成提前下班，但他今天确实有跟他的马医生的预约，所以他加入了。甚至连来自康涅狄格州的玛西·G也发现了一个小细节，每次我看到它都会让我觉得很有趣。在冷开场中，当他们捉弄一个正在睡觉的迈克尔，让他以为已经是下午5点时，他们必须更改他手表上的时间。帕姆把鞋子脱了，这样她在他的办公室里就不会发出声音。
But if you notice, Dwight also has his shoes off while he runs outside to change the time on Michael's car. I saw that. Jim also has his shoes off. Yes. Did everyone just take their shoes off? We had another fan catch from Lloyd C from Australia who said, during Jim's talking head, when he goes to turn the clock forward, the time starts on 12.50.
但如果你注意到的话，德怀特在跑出去更改迈克尔车上的时间时也把鞋子脱了。我看到了。吉姆也把鞋子脱了。是的。难道每个人都把鞋子脱了吗？我们收到了来自澳大利亚的劳埃德·C的另一个粉丝发现，他说，在吉姆的独白镜头中，当他去把时钟拨快时，时间是从12点50分开始的。
But when Dwight goes to Michael's car to change the time, it starts at 12.10. He said, was this a continuity gap, or did Dwight's panther speed turn time backwards outside of the office? I think it was probably just a continuity catch. Maybe they had originally intended to see Dwight running outside to the car first and then have Jim explain it in his talking head, and then maybe they just swapped it in editing. I bet that's right, because Vada would have been all on top of this. She had everything meticulously time-coded every time we had a clock.
但当德怀特去迈克尔的车上改时间时，时间是从12点10分开始的。他说，这是一个连贯性漏洞，还是德怀特的速度快得像黑豹，能让办公室外面的时间倒流？我想这可能只是一个连贯性捕捉。也许他们原本打算先看到德怀特跑出去到车边，然后让吉姆在独白中解释，接着可能他们在剪辑时把顺序调换了。我敢打赌是这样的，因为瓦达对这些了如指掌。每次我们有钟表时，她都把时间码记得一丝不苟。
She was very particular. So I feel like that was a change up in editing. Jenny Tan, who was there that day watching us film, noted that John had a really hard time winding the clock backwards and delivering his monologue and timing it out perfectly. I thought so watching it. I'll tell you why. John is so effortless as Jim, but in this moment, I could see him concentrating on that clock.
她非常挑剔。所以我感觉那是剪辑中的一次调整。当天在现场观看我们拍摄的珍妮·谭指出，约翰在把时钟往回拨、发表独白以及完美掌控时间方面遇到了很大的困难。我看的时候也这么觉得。我告诉你为什么。约翰作为吉姆表现得那么游刃有余，但在这一刻，我能看到他在集中精力对付那个时钟。
And just for a split second, I thought I saw John. Well, she said that the knob on the back was really, really tiny and that John kept overshooting the time. Like it kept ending on like 5.15 or 5.10 instead of right before 5. But she said they finally got it perfect on the last take, and then they stopped. They were like, we got it. Yeah, done. Well, this whole elaborate ruse ends when they all collectively on the count of three
就在那一瞬间，我觉得我看到了约翰。好吧，她说背后的那个旋钮非常非常小，约翰一直把时间拧过头。比如它总是停在5点15分或5点10分左右，而不是5点整之前。但她说他们在最后一条终于把它做完美了，然后他们停了下来。他们当时说，我们搞定了。是的，完成了。好吧，当他们所有人异口同声地数到三时，这个精心策划的恶作剧就结束了
just erupt into laughter. And this wakes Michael up, he laughs too, because he always wants to be in on the joke. Yes, yes. But you had to be there. You had to be there. It was a geography joke. And then Michael sees the clock and does exactly what they hoped for. He's like, well, let's all go home.
突然爆发出一阵大笑。这把迈克尔也吵醒了，他也跟着笑了起来，因为他总是想参与到笑话中去。是的，是的。但你得身临其境。你得在现场。那是个地理笑话。然后迈克尔看到了时钟，做出了他们期望的反应。他说，好吧，我们都回家吧。
I had a teeny tiny catch on Pam's desk at one minute 33 seconds when we're all laughing. I noticed, and I had forgotten this, that she has a prat mug on her desk that is what is holding all of her pens and pencils. And then she has her pink mug that she's drinking out of. But I spotted that prat mug. Aw. That's a great detail from our set decoration crew. Well, I love that.
我在帕姆的桌子上发现了一个微小的细节，在1分33秒我们都在笑的时候。我注意到，我之前把这事忘了，她的桌子上有一个普拉特马克杯，里面插满了她的钢笔和铅笔。然后她手里拿着她喝水的粉色马克杯。但我认出了那个普拉特马克杯。哦。这是来自我们的布景装饰团队的一个极好的细节。嗯，我很喜欢这个。
I was way in the corner, back by Stanley's file cabinet, and that was just trying to get me in the shot. Ken Quapas had me come out from accounting once again, I'm standing. And that's how we could all be there. Well now we have our super short opening credits. They are like 10 seconds, Jen Salata did an interview with Office Tally, and she said they cut the credits down to get more time for the episode. She mentioned that they had gone back and forth about maybe making this episode an hour,
我当时在角落里，靠近斯坦利的档案柜后面，那只是为了把我拍进镜头里。肯·夸帕斯让我再次从会计部走出来，我站着。这就是我们大家如何能同时出现在那里的。现在我们有了超级短的片头字幕。它们大约只有10秒钟，珍·萨拉塔接受了“办公室全记录”的采访，她说他们缩短了片头字幕，以便为剧集腾出更多时间。她提到他们曾反复讨论过是否要把这一集做成一个小时，
but she said they didn't feel like they needed it. There were other season finales like The Job or Goodbye Toby, where they had like tons of plot points to wrap up and huge moves they were going to make. But in this episode, she said they didn't have that much. They just had kind of the one big move with Jim and Pam, and a little bit of a move for Michael and Holly. And then the rest of us just little nods to our storylines. Yeah.
但她说他们觉得没必要。还有其他一些季终集，比如《工作》或《告别托比》，其中有大量的剧情线需要收尾，还有重大的搬迁行动。但在这一集中，她说过多的情节并没有。他们只有吉姆和帕姆之间的一个大进展，以及迈克尔和霍利之间的一点小进展。剩下的我们其他人只是对我们故事线的一些小暗示。是的。
But she said they did need to steal that little bit of time from the credits. The day has arrived. It is the Dunder Mifflin company picnic. Here's a breakdown of all the different branches and their t-shirts. Oh. Thank you, Dunderpedia. I started making notes, and then I saw you had it. So I'm going to read what you have, corporate black t-shirts, Akron yellow, Albany light
但她说他们确实需要从片头字幕里偷走那么一小段时间。这一天终于来了。这就是邓德·米弗林公司的野餐日。以下是对所有不同分公司及其T恤的盘点。哦。谢谢你，邓德百科。我开始做笔记，然后我看到你已经有了。所以我来宣读你有的内容，公司黑色T恤，阿克伦黄色，奥尔巴尼浅
blue, Buffalo orange, Nashua green, Rochester dark purple, Scranton red, and Utica dark blue. Lady, I'm calling this episode the plain hats club. Oh, I can't wait to hear this because I have some lingo I made up for this episode as well. Everyone in this episode is wearing a plain hat. And that is because if you wear a logo anywhere on your shirt or your hat, the production has to get it cleared with that company first. So I have a breakdown of everyone's plain hat.
蓝色，布法罗橙色，纳舒厄绿色，罗彻斯特深紫色，斯克兰顿红色，以及尤蒂卡深蓝色。女士，我把这一集叫做素色帽子俱乐部。哦，我等不及要听这个了，因为我为这一集也编造了一些行话。这一集里的每个人都戴着一顶素色帽子。那是因为如果你的衬衫或帽子上的任何地方带有标志，制作组就必须首先获得该公司的许可。所以我有一份关于每个人素色帽子的盘点。
Like the plain baseball hats? Yes. Jim is wearing a plain black baseball hat. Pam has a white visor. Dwight has a tan fishing hat, which I Googled and I learned is called a bucket hat. Kevin is also wearing a tan bucket hat. Angela has a floppy sun hat, Andy has a tan Panama hat, Aaron has a sort of light purple baseball hat, Creed has a light tan baseball hat, Ryan has a white visor, Stanley has
就像那种普通的棒球帽吗？是的。吉姆戴着一顶素黑色的棒球帽。帕姆戴着一个白色遮阳帽。德怀特戴着一顶棕褐色的渔夫帽，我谷歌了一下得知这叫盆帽。凯文也戴着一顶棕褐色的盆帽。安吉拉戴着一顶宽檐遮阳帽，安迪戴着一顶棕褐色的巴拿马草帽，艾琳戴着一顶有点浅紫色的棒球帽，克里德戴着一顶浅棕褐色的棒球帽，瑞恩戴着一个白色遮阳帽，斯坦利戴着
a straw sun hat, Phyllis has no hat while she's playing volleyball, but she has a straw sun hat on the sidelines, Meredith has no hat, Oscar has no hat, Charles Minor has a black Nike visor. How did we get away with that? I don't know. Because it's Idris and we're just like, let Idris do what he wants to do. We're just glad to have you back. I don't know.
一顶草帽，菲利斯在打排球时没戴帽子，但她在场边戴了一顶草帽，梅雷迪思没有戴帽子，奥斯卡没有戴帽子，查尔斯·迈纳戴着一顶黑色的耐克遮阳帽。我们是怎么逃过这一劫的？我不知道。因为那是伊德瑞斯，我们就像是，让伊德瑞斯做他想做的事吧。我们只是很高兴你能回来。我不知道。
Toby also has a yellow baseball hat with a logo. It has little trees, but I couldn't read what it was. Well you know, part of the hat strategy was because it got so hot during the day. We needed it. We needed it when we were playing volleyball as well to kind of create a shade on our faces so that you could see our expressions. So we weren't completely blown out by the sun, also for sun protection, but you might notice that Michael and Holly do not wear hats.
托比也戴着一顶带有标志的黄色棒球帽。上面有小树，但我看不清是什么。嗯，你知道，帽子策略的一部分是因为白天太热了。我们需要它。我们在打排球时也需要它来在脸上制造阴影，这样你就能看到我们的表情。这样我们就不会被太阳晒得完全过曝，也是为了防晒，但你可能会注意到迈克尔和霍利没有戴帽子。
They are mostly in their cutesy little like love nest shady area. Yeah, exactly. Well, Jenna, I also did a little bit of tracking. I want you to know that I feel like this episode really brings out some of our characters other traits. I made a list. We have Sporty Pam, Saucy Jim, Petty Charles, Trash Talking Andy, Snarky Michael, and my most favorite, Vacation Stanley.
他们大部分时间都待在他们可爱的小爱巢阴凉区里。是的，完全如此。好吧，珍娜，我还做了一点追踪。我想让你知道，我觉得这一集真的展现了我们某些角色的其他特质。我列了一个清单。我们有运动风帕姆、风骚吉姆、小肚鸡肠的查尔斯、喷垃圾话的安迪、尖酸刻薄的迈克尔，以及我最喜欢的，度假斯坦利。
I love Vacation Stanley. So the picnic starts with Pam and Jim. They're walking up and they share a little bit about what last year's softball company picnic was like. Jim had that spider in his mitt, but that's not what Pam is talking about. She's talking about the guy who grabbed her boobs to keep his balance. Uh-huh. And then Pam points at her chest and says, yeah, you don't grab these for balance.
我喜欢度假斯坦利。所以野餐从帕姆和吉姆开始。他们走过来，分享了一点去年的垒球公司野餐是什么样的。吉姆的手套里有那只蜘蛛，但这并不是帕姆在谈论的。她说的是那个为了保持平衡而抓她胸部的家伙。呃-huh。然后帕姆指着自己的胸口说，是的，你不能为了平衡去抓这些。
And Jim goes, well, and this is Saucy Jim. Well, next up, Dwight arrives with his friend, Rolf, his best friend, who they met at a shoe store when Dwight overheard Rolf asking for a shoe that would increase his speed but not leave any tracks. These two are made for each other. We had a fan question from David H. in Pennsylvania, who played Dwight's friend? Was he somehow related to the show already? Guys, Rolf was played by the amazing James Urbaniac.
吉姆说，好吧，这就是风骚吉姆。好吧，接下来，德怀特和他的朋友罗尔夫一起到了，这是他的好朋友，他们是在一家鞋店认识的，当时德怀特无意中听到罗尔夫在买一双能增加速度但不会留下任何足迹的鞋子。这俩人真是天生一对。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州的戴维·H的粉丝提问，扮演德怀特朋友的是谁？他之前是不是和这部剧有什么亲戚关系？伙计们，罗尔夫是由了不起的詹姆斯·乌巴尼亚克扮演的。
And get the sandwich. But he auditioned and was called back for the role of Dwight. Well, that makes perfect sense to me. Doesn't it? He and Ray knew each other from their New York theater days. And after Rayne read this script, he called James and gave him a heads up. And he told Greg, you need to bring in James Urbaniac for this. Well, they knew him because they had auditioned him.
而且还拿到了三明治。但他曾为德怀特这个角色试镜并被召回复试。好吧，这对我来说完全说得通。不是吗？他和雷恩从纽约戏剧界的时候就认识了。在雷恩读了这个剧本后，他给詹姆斯打了个电话并提前给他通了气。他告诉格里格，你需要让詹姆斯·乌巴尼亚克来演这个。好吧，他们认识他是因为他们曾经给他试镜过。
So he went in to see Alison Jones. He read for the role and he got the part. Ben talked a little bit in the DVD commentary about just how perfectly cast James was. And that for a guest star to come in on such a big episode, James just fit in so seamlessly, you would have never known he had never been on the show before. That is just how organic his performance was and that he just crushed it. Well, he's one of those guys who's been a working actor for a very, very long time. And I feel like he's one of those people where you recognize him immediately from his body
所以他去见了艾莉森·琼斯。他为这个角色试镜并得到了这个角色。本在DVD评论中谈到詹姆斯的选角是多么完美。对于一个客串演员来说，在一个如此重要的剧集中登场，詹姆斯无缝地融入其中，你绝不会知道他以前从未演过这部剧。他的表演就是那么自然，而且他表现得太棒了。嗯，他是那种当了很久很久专业演员的人。我觉得他就是那种你会从他的作品中一眼认出来的人。
of work. Well, we got this interesting letter from Janna M. in Westport County, Mayo, Ireland. Oh, wow. We have letters from everywhere. This is so exciting to me. You know, we added a feature on the website where you can say where you're writing from. I love that. I know me too, because it's really fun to see how international the show is.
作品。嗯，我们收到了来自爱尔兰梅奥郡韦斯特波特的詹娜·M的一封有趣的信。哦，哇。我们收到了来自世界各地的信件。这让我太兴奋了。你知道的，我们在网站上添加了一个功能，你可以说明你是在哪里写信的。我很喜欢这个。我知道我也是，因为看到这部剧有多么国际化真的很有趣。
I know. Well, when we get mail here to Earwolf that I open, I can always see where people are from. But before in emails, we weren't always sure. Here is what Janna said. In fact, James Urbaniak, the actor who played Dwight's best friend, Rolf, whom he met in a shoe store, also played a shoe store employee with a foot fetish on Sex in the City. What is it about James Urbaniak in shoe stores?
我知道。嗯，当我们在厄尔沃尔夫收到我打开的邮件时，我总是能看到人们来自哪里。但在以前的电子邮件中，我们并不总是能确定。詹娜是这么说的。事实上，扮演德 Dwight 最好朋友罗尔夫的演员詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克，也就是德怀特在鞋店遇到的那个人，还在《欲望都市》中扮演过一个有足恋的鞋店员工。詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克和鞋店有什么不解之缘吗？
That's really funny. I think that's fun. And now Christine B. from Mississippi asked this, I've heard that Rolf was introduced because Moe's was busy on Parks and Rec. Is that true? Oh, savvy question. It is true. You guys, originally, Moe's was supposed to come to the picnic with Dwight and they called
这真的很有趣。我觉得这很有意思。现在密西西比州的克里斯蒂娜·B问了这样一个问题，我听说罗尔夫的引入是因为莫斯在忙着拍《公园与游憩》。是真的吗？哦，精明的问题。是真的。你们知道的，原本莫斯应该和德怀特一起去野餐，他们打电话
up Mike Scherr, who was now running Parks and Rec. And the week we shot company picnic, he was directing an episode of Parks and Rec, as well as running the show. And he was like, you guys, I can't do it. And I guess they begged him, like Jen and Paul, they were like, please, you have to come be Moe's and he's like, you guys, I can't do it. I am running a whole other show now. Yes.
给迈克·舒尔，他现在负责《公园与游憩》。在我们拍摄公司野餐的那周，他正在导演一集《公园与游憩》，同时还要负责整个节目。他说，伙计们，我做不到。我猜他们求了他，就像珍和保罗一样，他们说，求求你，你必须来扮演莫斯，而他说，伙计们，我做不到。我现在在负责另一个全新的节目。是的。
And then, you know, we're going to have Mike on the show. I can't wait. And he's going to tell us a little bit about how he also truly hated playing Moe's. Hated it. Hated it. So I think he was like really happy that he had a good excuse to not be out in this field in his wool clothes for four days. That also made sense to me that Dwight wouldn't have brought Moe's to the company picnic.
然后，你知道的，我们要请迈克上节目。我等不及了。他要给我们讲讲他是多么真正地讨厌扮演莫斯。讨厌它。讨厌它。所以我觉得他真的很庆幸自己有一个很好的借口，不用穿着羊毛衣服在这个田野里呆四天。这对我来说也很合理，德怀特是不会带莫斯去公司野餐的。
And I love this twist that he's got this best friend. Yeah. You know, there's a deleted talking head that made me laugh, but also sad, where Michael says he usually brings the guy from Escondo with him. But this year, he came by himself. The guy from Escondo. Yeah. Well, Rolf is going to appear in four episodes of The Office.
我喜欢这个反转，他竟然有这样一个最好的朋友。是的。你知道，有一个被删掉的谈话头（Talking Head）让我笑了，但也感到难过，迈克尔在其中说他通常带着那个来自埃斯孔迪多的家伙一起来。但今年，他自己一个人来了。那个来自埃斯孔迪多的家伙。是的。嗯，罗尔夫将在《办公室》的四集中出现。
This was his first. We loved you, James. He was really fun to work with. So fun. Now enters Holly. Aw. And Michael, Caesar, and Kevin's like, there's Holly, and Michael's like, oh, you know, we're just friends.
这是他的第一次。我们爱你，詹姆斯。和他合作真的很有趣。太有趣了。现在霍莉登场了。哦。迈克尔、凯撒和凯文就像是，看那是霍莉，而迈克尔则说，哦，你知道的，我们只是朋友。
There's a whole awkward greeting between Holly and her boyfriend, AJ, with Michael. And Jenna, this begins snarky, Michael. Steve does this thing as Michael, I love so much, where he lets his hatred for someone just barely poke out. So he says, hey, I could get you guys some lemonade. Holly says, lemonade sounds great. Michael goes, OK, AJ says, I'd love an iced tea, actually, and Michael goes, you can go to hell.
霍莉和她的男友AJ与迈克尔之间有一段非常尴尬的打招呼。珍娜，这就开始了刻薄的迈克尔。史蒂夫作为迈克尔做了一件事，我太喜欢了，他让对某人的厌恶稍微流露出来。所以他说，嘿，我可以给你们拿点柠檬水。霍莉说，柠檬水听起来不错。迈克尔说，好的，AJ说，其实我很想来杯冰茶，迈克尔说，你可以去死吧。
Just kidding. Just kidding. He'll get him the best iced tea in the world. Yeah. First of all, Rob Hubel is back as AJ, and he's so good. He's being so nice to Michael. I know. The whole episode, you're like, oh, my gosh, this guy must really love Holly to be that
开玩笑的。开玩笑的。他会给他拿世界上最好的冰茶。是的。首先，罗伯·许贝尔作为AJ回归了，他太棒了。他对迈克尔太好了。我知道。整集看下来，你会想，哦，天哪，这家伙一定真的很爱霍莉，才能对迈克尔那么
patient with Michael. I want to point out in this scene that Kevin is having a beer. Yes. Holly asks for a lemonade, AJ wants an iced tea, according to a big banner in the background. You can really see it over Michael's shoulder in his upcoming talking head. There is a breakdown of everything the Dunder Mifflin Company picnic is serving. Oh. The food was hamburgers, turkey burgers, hot dogs, corn on the cob, salads.
有耐心。我想在这场戏中指出，凯文在喝啤酒。是的。霍莉要柠檬水，AJ想要冰茶，根据背景中的一个大横幅。你真的可以在迈克尔即将进行的谈话头时从他的肩膀上方看到它。那里列出了邓德米夫林公司野餐提供的所有食物。哦。食物有火鸡汉堡、热狗、玉米棒、沙拉。
Listen to the beverage list, pina colada. Charles drinks one of those. My tie. Stanley drinks one of those. Hurricane. Oh, wow. Tequila sunrise. Dang.
听听饮料单，皮娜科拉达（椰林飘香）。查尔斯喝了那个。迈泰。斯坦利喝了那个。飓风。哦，哇。龙舌兰日出。天哪。
Beer, wine, sodas, water. No iced tea. No lemonade. No ice. Lots of booze. Lots of booze. Lots of booze, you know, Michael has a talking head where he says, I lied to Kevin, Holly and I could never just be friends and he wrote a whole list of bullet points of why they
啤酒、葡萄酒、苏打水、水。没有冰茶。没有柠檬水。没有冰块。有很多酒。有很多酒。有很多酒，你知道的，迈克尔有一个谈话头，在其中他说，我对凯文撒了谎，我和霍莉绝不可能只是朋友，他写了一整串为什么他们
should be together on like a receipt, on some kind of receipt. He didn't use a proper piece of paper. No. And he's trying to read it and he can't really make out what he wrote. He said, there are soup snakes. And then he tries to justify it by being like, I think, okay, yeah, I think it's because when we have soup. And then he's like, no, no, soulmates.
应该在一起的要点，写在收据上，某种收据上。他没有用一张像样的纸。没有。他在试图读它，却辨认不出自己写了什么。他说，有汤蛇。然后他试图通过这样的话来为自己开脱，我想，好吧，是的，我想这是因为当我们喝汤时。然后他说，不，不，灵魂伴侣。
Well, we had a fan question from Tracy C. and Georgia who said this, I have been holding on to this fast fact for so long, please include it in this episode. What is it? Mindy describes her and BJ's relationship as soup snakes because she loves the scene where Michael misreads his own handwriting. And instead of saying that he and Holly are soulmates, he says, they are soup snakes. You guys, this is true. In Mindy's book, Why Not Me?
嗯，我们收到了来自佐治亚州特雷シー·C的一个粉丝提问，她是这样说的，我保留这个快速事实太久了，请把它收录在这集里。是什么？敏迪把她和BJ的关系描述为汤蛇，因为她喜欢迈克尔误读自己笔迹的那场戏。他没有说他和霍莉是灵魂伴侣，而是说，他们是汤蛇。你们看，这是真的。在敏迪的书《为什么不是我？》中
Here's what it says, quote, we're soup snakes, BJ and I are soup snakes. And then she added soulmates is what you aim for, but soup snakes is what you get sometimes. Aw. Is that so sweet? Yeah. They are soup snakes. They are soup snakes. Come and jam.
她是这么写的，引述道，我们是汤蛇，BJ和我都是汤蛇。然后她补充说，灵魂伴侣是你的目标，但汤蛇有时才是你得到的。哦。是不是太甜了？是的。他们是汤蛇。他们是汤蛇。来吧，我们Jam一下。
We're going to say hi to Charles, who right out of the gate says nice day, huh? Jim says, yeah, Charles says must be nice to get a rest from all your rest and walks away. I call this petty Charles. I want you to know Charles was way more snarky in this episode, but a lot of it got deleted. Oh no. Yeah. Well, Jenny Tan said that when she was kind of going around talking to all the actors,
我们要和查尔斯打招呼，他一开口就说今天天气不错哈？吉姆说，是的，查尔斯说从你所有的休息中得到休息一定很不错，然后走开了。我管这叫小肚鸡肠的查尔斯。我想让你们知道，查尔斯在这集中要刻薄得多，但其中很大一部分被删掉了。哦不。是的。嗯，珍妮·坦说过，当她四处和所有演员交谈时，
she said both Rob Hubel and Idris talked to her about what it was like to have fans hate on them. Oh, really? Yes. Because Charles was always mean to Jim, but I have to say, lady, he is not wrong on his read of Jim. Like Jim is very charming, but he, I mean- He slacks off.
她说罗伯·许贝尔和伊德里斯都跟她谈过被粉丝讨厌是什么感觉。哦，真的吗？是的。因为查尔斯对吉姆一直很苛刻，但我不得不说，女士，他对吉姆的看法并没有错。就像吉姆很有魅力，但他，我是说——他在偷懒。
He is a slacker. He gets his work done ultimately, but he could be more ambitious with his time. Well, yeah, that comes for him later in life. He will become more ambitious in later seasons. All right, lady, it is time to play volleyball. Yeah. Dwight is assigning positions to the Scranton team. Andy is like, bro, me, go, put Aaron next to me, all of Andy's ridiculous things.
他是个懒虫。他最终能完成工作，但他在时间分配上可以更有野心。嗯，是的，那在他人生的后期才会到来。他在后面的几季中会变得更有野心。好了，女士，是时候打排球了。是的。德怀特正在给斯克兰顿队分配位置。安迪说，兄弟，我，上，把艾伦安排在我旁边，安迪所有的荒谬事情。
Bro, me, go, it's pretty great. Well, guess what? The Scranton team is not doing well. Aaron misses the ball. He starts screaming at her, are you blind? And then he catches himself and he redirects the question in earnest to the man on the other side of the net wearing sunglasses. He's like, no, I'm really, are you blind?
兄弟，我，上，这挺棒的。好吧，你猜怎么着？斯克兰顿队表现不好。艾伦没接到球。他开始对她尖叫，你瞎了吗？然后他回过神来，把这个问题真诚地转向了网另一侧戴着太阳镜的男士。他说，不，我真的，你瞎了吗？
Guess what? Sunglasses man was played by our very own editor, Dave Rogers. Yeah. But the game continues. Kevin is not great. Phyllis sits down in the middle of the game. Ryan is on his cell phone. Yeah.
你猜怎么着？戴太阳镜的男士是由我们自己的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯扮演的。是的。但比赛继续。凯文表现一般。菲莉丝在比赛中途坐下了。瑞安在玩手机。是的。
And now it's time for Pam to serve. And Dwight is like condescending. He's like, are you left-handed or are you right-handed? Think about how you hold the phone. And Pam's like, you know what, Dwight? Back off. Mm-hmm. I got it.
现在轮到帕姆发球了。德怀特态度居高临下。他说，你是左撇子还是右撇子？想想你是怎么拿电话的。帕姆说，你知道吗，德怀特？靠边站。嗯哼。我搞得定。
This is sporty Pam. Oh, she spikes that serve. She does. And then she's like, maybe I played a little in junior high and in high school, maybe a little in college, and went to volleyball camp most, and you do this really cute thing to know where you go, Samas. Well, this created a fan mail flurry lady. It did?
这是运动型的帕姆。哦，她扣球发球了。她确实做到了。然后她说，也许我在初中和高中打过一点，也许在大学打过一点，大部分时间都去过排球营，你做了一个非常可爱的动作，你知道你去，萨马斯。嗯，这引发了一场粉丝来信的风暴，女士。真的吗？
Oh, yes. You know, Rose G from Colorado sums up all the letters nicely by saying, in season four, Pam says that she used PMS as an excuse to get out of volleyball gym class. But here, Pam is real good at volleyball. What is up with this plot inconsistency? Now, we did discuss this when we broke down Job Fair. You had your theory. Yes.
哦，是的。你知道，来自科罗拉多的罗斯·G很好地总结了所有的信件，她说，在第四季中，帕姆说她用经前综合症作为借口逃避排球体育课。但在这里，帕姆排球打得非常好。这个剧情前后矛盾是怎么回事？现在，当我们剖析《招聘会》时，我们确实讨论过这个问题。你当时有你的理论。是的。
It was a fan theory that Pam wanted out of the non-competitive gym class volleyball. This is a very kind theory. This is like, I mean, this is a very kind, kind, like, let's just make any excuse. Well, Jen Salata did an interview for Office Telly, and she admitted they just forgot about that line when they wrote this. Of course they did. They didn't strategically plot out like, you know what, Pam was so competitive. She didn't want to do PE volleyball.
这是一个粉丝理论，认为帕姆想逃避那个不具竞争性的体育课排球。这是一个非常善良的理论。这就像是，我的意思是，这是一个非常善良、善良的理论，比如，让我们找任何借口吧。嗯，珍·萨拉塔为《办公室电视》做了一次采访，她承认他们在写这段时只是把那句台词忘了。他们当然忘了！他们才不会煞费苦心地策划，你知道的，帕姆是如此好胜。她才不想上体育课打排球呢。
Right. She still liked that theory. I know. I know. Pam continues to dominate. She wins the game for her team, advances them to the next round because I am just that good. Yeah.
对。她还是喜欢那个理论。我懂。我懂。帕姆继续占据主导地位。她为她的团队赢得了比赛，让他们晋级下一轮，因为我就是这么棒。耶。
Well, I have a kid catch. What's the kid catch? So my kids rewatched this episode with me. They could not get over at seven minutes, 43 seconds. There is a full-on face body plant. This must have been someone with special business as volleyball because when Pam serves, you've got to look at the person who misses the ball. They throw themselves.
嗯，我有一个关于小孩的趣事。什么小孩的趣事？所以我的孩子们和我一起重温了这一集。他们在七分四十三秒的时候简直不敢相信。有一个彻底的脸着地、身体倒地的镜头。这一定是某个排球专业人士，因为当帕姆发球时，你得看看那个没接到球的人。他们自己摔了出去。
They fly through the air and they land in one clump face down. I was like, is this a stunt person? I mean, Jenna, I have to show it to you. I'm going to put it in stories. This is how this person lands. Oh my gosh, that person did not even break their fall with their arms. I know. That is intense.
他们在空中飞过，然后以一团人脸朝下的姿态落地。当时我就想，这是替身演员吗？我是说，珍娜，我得把它展示给你。我要把它发到快拍里。这就是这个人落地的方式。哦天哪，那个人甚至都没用手臂缓冲落地。我知道。太激烈了。
Well, I have a tidbit to share about that. Okay. But first, let me do some fan questions. Peyton H. from Vermont said, Jenna, I know there was a stunt double for you and some of your volleyball scenes, but my question is how much was you and how much was the stunt double? And Megan B. from Jerome, Idaho said, have you played much volleyball in real life? All right.
好吧，我有一个关于这个的八卦要分享。好的。但首先，让我回答一些粉丝提问。来自佛蒙特州的佩顿·H（Peyton H.）说：“珍娜，我知道你在一些排球场景中使用了替身，但我的问题是，有多少是你自己完成的，又有多少是替身完成的？”来自爱达荷州杰罗姆的梅根·B（Megan B.）说：“你在现实生活中打过很多排球吗？”好啦。
I'm going to break down all the volleyball. I love all these questions, you guys. I love them because, you know, I know the answer to some of them and others I'm intrigued. I have played a lot of volleyball. You don't say. I have. When? In like grade school, high school, my youth at the beach.
我要把所有的排球场景都剖析一遍。我喜欢所有这些问题，你们大家。我喜欢它们，因为，你知道，有些问题的答案我知道，而其他的则让我很感兴趣。我打过很多排球。你别说。我真的打过。什么时候？大概是小学、高中，还有我年轻时在海滩上。
I know how to play volleyball and I have a really great underhand serve. So do I. Very consistent. Yes. Nothing fancy, but we'll always get in. Same. They didn't want that for Pam. I offered to do it.
我知道怎么打排球，而且我有一个非常棒的低手发球。我也是。非常稳定。是的，虽然没什么花哨的，但总是能发过去。一样。他们不希望帕姆那样。我主动提出要自己上。
They weren't interested. They wanted overhand serve. Because you know in varsity high school, you have to serve overhand. I did not know that. I did not play varsity. I know this because my daughter's playing volleyball. She is. In junior high, she can still do underhand, but they're wanting them already to do overhand.
他们不感兴趣。他们想要高手发球。因为你知道在高中校队里，你必须用高手发球。我以前不知道。我没有打过校队。我知道这个是因为我女儿在打排球。她确实在打。在初中，她还可以用低手发球，但他们已经要求他们必须用高手发球了。
Well, here was the problem. I have a shoulder injury. I have tendonitis in my right shoulder and it's really bad. I have a lack of range of motion and doing that overhead swoopy motion, it's even a little sore. I'm doing it now. It's even a little bit sore if I'm holding nothing in my hand or if I'm not hitting a volleyball.
好吧，问题在于：我肩膀有伤。我右肩有肌腱炎，而且真的很严重。我的活动范围受限，做出那种头顶挥臂的动作甚至会有点酸痛。我现在正在做这个动作。即使我手里什么都没拿，或者即使我没有击打排球，它也甚至会有点酸痛。
What? Why are you laughing? Why is it so funny? What? I was just going to say, and alias, oh my God, you're still tracking why I can't be on alias? I will for the rest of my life. How can you swing on a rope and like do a cartwheel and like throw a grenade or whatever
什么？你笑什么？为什么这么好笑？什么？我刚才只是想说，还有《双面女间谍》（Alias），哦天哪，你还在纠结为什么我不能演《双面女间谍》？我一辈子都会纠结。你怎么能在绳子上荡来荡去，还能做侧手翻，还能扔手榴弹或者别的什么
she did? I mean, you're making a good point. Okay, go on. I hadn't thought about that. They didn't ask me in my audition how my overhand range of motion was. Well, that might have rolled it out. They shouldn't have even auditioned me for that role. There's no way I could have swung on a rope.
她做过的事？我的意思是，你切入点很好。好吧，继续。我之前没想过这个。他们在试镜时没有问我高手发球的活动范围。好吧，那可能会让我落选。他们甚至不应该让我去试镜那个角色。我绝对不可能在绳子上荡来荡去。
All right, well, listen, they had to get me a stunt double. Her name was Nancy McCrum and Randy was kind enough to send me her photo, which we'll post in the Office Lady pod stories. And he sent me her resume. And her resume, it shows her height and her weight, which I just want to say, I can't believe I used to weigh that. Oh, because they matched her height and weight to you. Yes, when they find you a body double or a stunt double, they have to match the person's
好吧，听着，他们必须为我找一个特技替身。她的名字叫南希·麦克鲁姆（Nancy McCrum），兰迪（Randy）很友好地把她的照片发给了我，我们会把它发到《办公室女士》播客的快拍里。他还把她的简历发给了我。她的简历上写着她的身高和体重，我只想说，我真不敢相信我以前有那么重。哦，因为他们把她的身高和体重匹配到了你身上？是的，当他们为你找一个替身演员或特技替身时，他们必须匹配这个人的
height, the weight, the general hair color, or they'll put a wig on the person or color that person's hair. But it's more than that because I was on this one movie and they had to get a body double for me and the woman showed up and she was my height and weight, but her weight distribution was totally different from mine. So walking and- She didn't look like me. She didn't look like you.
身高、体重、大致的头发颜色，或者他们会给这个人戴上假发或把这个人的头发染成相应颜色。但不仅如此，因为我曾经拍过一部电影，他们不得不为我找一个替身演员，那个女人出现时，她的身高和体重跟我一样，但她的体重分布和我的完全不同。所以走路和——她看起来不像我。她看起来不像你。
This happened to me, Jenna. I did a movie called Struck by Lightning and there was this long tracking dolly scene that started in a room and ended up on the sofa that I was sitting on. And they had a body double for me for all the lighting setup because it was going to take a really long time to get this set up. So after an hour of them setting this all up, using the body double, it's time for me to report on set. We do this long intricate tracking shot.
这事也发生在我身上，珍娜。我拍过一部叫《击中雷电》（Struck by Lightning）的电影，有一个很长的跟拍轨道镜头，从一个房间开始，最后停在我正坐着的沙发上。为了所有的灯光设置，他们为我准备了一个替身演员，因为把这个场景布置好需要很长时间。所以在他们花了一个小时用替身演员把这一切都布置好之后，轮到我去片场报到了。我们拍摄了这个漫长而复杂的跟拍镜头。
The camera's coming down this long track, lands on me on the sofa and it cuts part of my head off. Well, what they found out was she was my exact height. They immediately called for her because the director of photography had set up all this time for the shot and he said, are you 5'1"? And she said, yes. And she came and stood next to me. We were the same height and then he said, sit side by side.
摄像机顺着这条长长的轨道下来，落在我这个坐在沙发上的人身上，结果切掉了我的一部分头。好吧，他们发现的是，她和我的身高一模一样。他们立刻把她叫了过来，因为摄影指导为这个镜头花了很长时间进行设置，他说：“你身高五尺一寸吗？”她说是的。然后她过来站在我旁边。我们身高一样，然后他说：“并排坐着。”
We sat side by side. I had a longer torso than she did. Yes! This is what I'm saying. So they had to like measure her like did we have the same waist, the circumference of your thigh, like all of that. And Nancy McCrum was just an exact body double for me. Well I could never tell that there was a body double there so they did a great job.
我们并排坐着。我的躯干比她长。是的！这就是我要说的。所以他们不得不测量她，比如我们是否有相同的腰围、大腿周长之类的。而南希·麦克鲁姆恰好是我的完美身材替身。好吧，我从来没看出那里有个替身，所以他们做得太棒了。
Well here's what I did. She was also very good at volleyball and she taught me how to do the motion, how to jump up, how to serve it and all of that. And I did a whole, whole bunch of takes and we used a CGI ball. So that you didn't have to actually make the contact. Yeah. Randy reminded me that the very first time I tried to do it by making contact with the ball and I like winced in pain and he was like, no, no, no more ball.
好吧，我是这么做的。她也很擅长打排球，她教我如何做动作，如何跳起来，如何发球等等。我拍了非常非常多的镜头，我们使用的是一个CGI球。这样你就不用真的去击球了。对。兰迪提醒我，我第一次尝试通过接触球来完成这个动作时，我疼得龇牙咧嘴，然后他说：“不，不，再也不要球了。”
We're never having her do that again because like we said, he was so good at taking care of us. He was like, we're going to do a CGI ball. But he said while the serving and putting in a fake ball was not difficult, it was really difficult to have people dive for a fake ball. Yes. So that person that is diving in that video you just showed me is diving at nothing. Well that might...
我们绝不会让她再那样做了，因为正如我们所说，他非常擅长照顾我们。他说：“我们要用一个CGI球。”但他说，虽然发球和放入一个假球并不困难，但让人们为一个假球扑救却非常困难。是的。所以你在刚才给我看的那个视频里扑救的那个人是在对着空气扑救。好吧，那可能……
That commitment. That might make sense a little bit. And the DVD commentary kin was very complimentary in saying that Jenna, you did great, fakey arm motion. Yeah. Well, I have to give credit to Nancy because she was such a good teacher. We became a little chummy on this episode and they did shoot with her a little bit from behind with a real ball and that was really helpful for the people on the other side because
那种投入度。那可能有点说得通。DVD评论里基恩（Kin）非常赞赏地说，珍娜，你做了一个很棒的假装手臂动作。是的。好吧，我必须把功劳归于南希，因为她是一位非常好的老师。我们在这一集里变得有点亲密了，他们确实用真球从后面拍摄了她一点点，这对于另一边的人来说真的很有帮助，因为
then they were diving for a real ball and they used some of those shots, but I'm not sure if they ever ended up using any of her serves. I think they were mostly my fakey serves that made it in. But I do want to say one more thing, which is that over on OfficeTelly.com, Jenny Tan took a bunch of amazing photos of me serving with no ball. Oh, really? And they're really cool. And I grabbed them so that we can put them up on Office Ladies Pod.
然后他们是在为一个真球扑救，他们确实使用了一些那样的镜头，但我不太确定他们最后是否真的使用了她的任何发球。我想大部分进入正片的都是我假装发球的镜头。但我确实还想说一件事，那就是在OfficeTelly.com网站上，珍妮·谭（Jenny Tan）拍了许多我手里没球却在发球的精彩照片。哦，真的吗？而且它们真的很酷。我把它们保存下来了，这样我们就可以把它们发到《办公室女士》播客上了。
Your story about Nancy, Jenna, just reminded me of an amazing run-in I just had. For years, Steve had a body double named Eric Sulke and Jenna, Josh and I were in the wine country for our anniversary and I hear Angela and I turn around and there is Eric and his wife. No way. He is still working with Steve. It's been like 16 years they've been working together. They're working together on a movie right now.
珍娜，你关于南希的故事让我想起了一次刚刚经历的奇妙偶遇。多年来，史蒂夫（Steve）一直有一个名叫埃里克·苏尔克（Eric Sulke）的替身演员，珍娜，乔什（Josh）和我为了庆祝我们的结婚纪念日去到了葡萄酒之乡，我听到有人喊安吉拉，我一转身，就看到了埃里克和他的妻子。不会吧。他还在跟史蒂夫合作。他们合作大约有16年了。他们现在正一起合作一部电影。
Look at that. Oh my gosh. Yes. I remember him. I know he was so lovely and I said, Eric, it's so crazy to see you outside of a suit because he was just in casual clothes. But sometimes when Steve needed out for something they had to get him to a talk show or whatever, Eric in a suit would sit in the office there in the background in Michael Scott's office.
你看。哦天哪。是的。我记得他。我知道他非常可爱，我对他说：“埃里克，看到你穿着便装而不是西装真是太疯狂了，”因为他当时只穿着休闲服。但有时当史蒂夫因为什么事需要离开，他们必须让他去脱口秀节目或其他地方时，穿着西装的埃里克就会坐在办公室背景里迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）的办公室里。
You could catch his shoulder or the side of him and they are still working together now, 16 years. I love that. Me too. Well, listen, ladies, should we take a little break and then when we come back, we will talk about Michael and Holly and what they're up to? Yeah. I think we need to come back and talk about some chair pants.
你可以拍到他的肩膀或他的侧面，而且他们现在还在合作，整整16年。我太喜欢这个了。我也是。好吧，听着，女士们，我们要不要稍微休息一下，等我们回来后，我们将聊聊迈克尔和霍莉以及他们在忙些什么？好的。我觉得我们需要回来聊聊椅子裤。
Oh, great. We're back and also Snarky and Michael is with us. He gets a big piece of news here. He really does blesses hard. They tell him that they're designing a house. He says, for who? And AJ says, for us. And then Michael says, well, wow, I'm designing a chair.
太棒了。我们回来了，尖酸刻薄的迈克尔也和我们在一起。他在这里得到了一个重大消息。他真的可以说是深受打击。他们告诉他他们在设计一栋房子。他说：“为谁设计的？”AJ说：“为我们。”然后迈克尔说：“哦，哇，我在设计一把椅子。”
It's part of your pants. You sit down. You're supported. Holly lights up. She's like, I remember your chair pants idea. And AJ's like, I like that. Put me down for a pair. I'm a size 34 waist.
它是你裤子的一部分。你坐下来。你就能得到支撑。霍莉眼睛一亮。她说：“我记得你的椅子裤创意。”AJ说：“我喜欢那个。算我一双。我腰围34英寸。”
Here comes Snarky, Michael. He can't take it anymore. He says, all right, Fatty, I will do it. You know what? We should actually rehearse. He wants to get Holly away from AJ. And AJ says, you guys are really going to do this? And Michael says, you bet your fat ass we are because you can't contain like how much
尖酸刻薄的迈克尔来了。他再也受不了了。他说：“好吧，胖子，我来做。”你知道吗？我们其实应该排练一下。他想把霍莉从AJ身边引开。AJ说：“你们俩真的要这么做吗？”迈克尔说：“你敢打赌我们会的，因为你根本无法控制到底有多”
he's freaking out that this guy has just swooped in and is taking the love of his life. To build a house. To build a house. To build a home. To become a family. Oh. Well, we have this really sweet talking head where Michael and Holly together explain that David Wallace has authorized them to perform a presentation on the history of Dunder Nifflin.
这家伙突然冒出来，抢走了他一生的挚爱，他为此快要急疯了。去盖一所房子。去盖一所房子。去建一个家。去组成一个家庭。哦。好吧，我们有一段非常甜蜜的访谈，迈克尔和霍莉在其中一起解释说，大卫·华莱士授权他们进行一场关于邓德米夫林历史的演讲。
Again, David Wallace, what are you thinking? I don't know. Well, Holly and Michael are going to find a nice little quiet place to rehearse. He brought her chocolate covered strawberries. When I rewatched this with my kids, they were like, wow, because I think they associate those with valentines. When you go to the grocery store, there's always a big chocolate covered strawberry display for valentines.
话说回来，大卫·华莱士，你在想什么呢？我不知道。好吧，霍莉和迈克尔要找个安静的小地方去排练。他给她带来了巧克力草莓。当我跟我的孩子们重温这一集时，他们觉得哇塞，因为我觉得他们把这东西和情人节联系在了一起。当你去杂货店时，总有一个很大的巧克力草莓展示区是为情人节准备的。
It's a very romantic gift. It is. What snacks do you bring to a picnic? You bring like potato chips, some salsa, chocolate covered strawberries. By the way, I love that your picnic items are potato chips and salsa. I have never brought potato chips and salsa. You don't like chips and salsa? But don't you eat corn chips or like?
这是一份非常浪漫的礼物。确实是的。你带什么零食去野餐？你会带薯片、一些莎莎酱、巧克力草莓。顺便说一句，我很喜欢你带的野餐食品居然是薯片和莎莎酱。我从来没带过薯片和莎莎酱。你难道不喜欢薯片蘸莎莎酱吗？但是你难道不吃玉米片或者类似的东西吗？
Tortilla chips. Okay, I'm sorry. But also, I've never brought salsa to a picnic blanket. It's so messy. The chips, yeah, but I don't bring dips to a picnic. I don't think dip when I think picnic. Lady, lady, when my husband first came home with me to meet my family, my mom said to him, we're dippers and chippers.
玉米饼干。好吧，对不起。而且，我也从来没在野餐垫上摆过莎莎酱。那太脏了。薯片可以，但我不带蘸酱去野餐。一想到野餐，我就不会联想到蘸酱。大姐，大姐，当我的丈夫第一次带我回家见我的家人时，我妈妈对他说，我们是狂热的蘸酱和薯片爱好者。
Okay. We always have some kind of dip and something like a chip to eat it with. Even on your picnics. Most definitely on a picnic. Okay. It just seems like a mess waiting to happen. Give me all the dips. All right.
好吧。我们总是准备某种蘸酱和诸如薯片之类可以用来蘸着吃的东西。甚至在你们野餐的时候也是。野餐时绝对会带。好吧。这看起来就像是一场即将发生的灾难。把所有的蘸酱都给我。好吧。
And you know, bring some paper towels. Well I have something crazy to share about this location where they shot these Michael and Holly scenes. The tree, the little shady tree? Yes. He said that this shaded location was the most troublesome of the whole shoot. Why? He said first off, they really wanted a romantic private area where these two could sneak off
而且你知道的，带点纸巾。嗯，关于他们拍摄迈克尔和霍莉这些场景的地点，我有一个疯狂的消息要分享。那棵树，那棵遮阴的小树？是的。他说这个有树荫的地方是整个拍摄过程中最麻烦的。为什么？他说首先，他们真的很想要一个浪漫的私密区域，让这两个人可以偷偷溜过去，
to, but they still needed to feel the picnic in the background. And it was really hard to find the right spot. The one that they settled on drove Randall crazy. I guess there were these overhanging trees and then there was like a muddy creek where his lighting equipment needed to go and we usually shot our show with just two cameras. But for this, they had to add a third camera. And it's because they just couldn't cover it with these over the shoulders. They looked good, but they really wanted a two shot of them from the front.
但他们又需要背景里能感觉到野餐的氛围。要找到合适的地方真的很难。他们最终选定的那个地方让兰德尔抓狂。我猜那里有伸出来的树枝，然后还有一个泥泞的小溪，他的灯光设备需要架在那里，我们通常只用两台摄像机来拍摄我们的节目。但对于这个场景，他们不得不增加第三台摄像机。这是因为他们实在无法仅通过过肩镜头来拍摄。这些镜头看起来不错，但他们真的很想要一个从正面拍摄两人的双人镜头。
But listen to this and I barely understand how they did it. Okay. It's so tight in this area that the only way that they could do it was they had to set up a mirror and they shot the camera into the mirror. And then in order to make it match over the shoulder shots, they reversed them in post because when they shot in the mirror, they were on the wrong sides. It was this like special mirror called like an optically correct mirror. I barely understand this, but it was a huge ordeal.
但听听这个，我几乎无法理解他们是怎么做到的。好吧。这个区域太狭窄了，他们能做到这一点的唯一方法就是架设一面镜子，然后他们对着镜子拍摄摄像机画面。为了让它与过肩镜头匹配，他们在后期制作中将其反转了，因为当他们对着镜子拍摄时，他们的方向左右颠倒了。这是一种被称为光学正确镜的特殊镜子。我几乎无法理解这一点，但这真是一场巨大的折磨。
Well it sounds like a huge ordeal. I'm also very curious, could Steve and Amy see their reflections as they did the scene? Cause that would be weird. I wouldn't, I don't want to watch myself because then I'd be like, what are you doing with your face, lady? What is that expression? I would be so distracted. Yeah.
听起来确实是一场巨大的折磨。我也很好奇，斯蒂夫和艾米在拍这场戏时能看到自己的倒影吗？因为那会很奇怪。我不会，我不想看自己，因为那样我会想：大姐，你脸上在做什么表情？那是什么表情？我会太分心的。对啊。
So I don't know. My question was like, did they just have this mirror on standby? Like is that part of their kit? They have an optically correct mirror in your camera kit. It sounds like a special order, but it also sounds like they kind of had to figure this out on the fly. But I don't know, maybe it was part of their planning scout. Get that mirror in case we needed and get a third camera.
所以我不知道。我的问题是，他们是随时备着这面镜子吗？就像那是他们器材的一部分？你们的摄像机套件里有一面光学正确的镜子？这听起来像是特殊订制的，但听起来他们也只能临场应变来解决这个问题。不过我不知道，也许这是他们勘景计划的一部分？以防我们需要的话就带上那面镜子，还要带第三台摄像机。
You would have never known it by watching that scene though. It was so beautiful and effortless. I would have never known there was a mirror or a third camera. There's this great, great moment between Holly and Michael is their brain storming their ideas, right? And yeah, they're going to do this skit, but this is the first time they've met to figure out the skit that's going to be going up soon. And Michael has no script.
不过看那场戏的时候，你绝对看不出来。它是那么优美和自然。我绝不会知道那里有一面镜子或第三台摄像机。霍莉和迈克尔之间有一个非常非常棒的时刻，就是他们头脑风暴想点子，对吧？是的，他们要做这个小品，但这是他们第一次碰面来构思这个即将上演的小品，而且迈克尔没有剧本。
He just wants to wing it. So they start spitballing like movie spoofs, right? To get out this information about how Robert Dunder and Robert Mifflin met. Only part of it was scripted, Jenna. Steve and Amy just improvised and Ken said they love the improv. They just let the camera keep going and going. Really? Yes.
他只想即兴发挥。于是他们开始像抛出电影恶搞点子那样天马行空地讨论，对吧？为了引出罗伯特·邓德和罗伯特·米夫林是如何相遇的这段信息。詹娜，其中只有一部分是有剧本的。斯蒂夫和艾米完全是即兴发挥，肯说他们非常喜欢这种即兴表演。他们就让摄像机一直拍下去，一直拍下去。真的吗？是的。
Here's how the scene started as written. Holly's like, what about back to the future? Yeah. That was scripted. The rest of this part was not ready. Yeah. How about back to the future? Steve improvises.
场景刚开始时的剧本是这样的。霍莉说：“《回到未来》怎么样？”是的。那是剧本里写好的。这部分的其余内容是没有准备好的。对啊。《回到未来》怎么样？斯蒂夫即兴发挥。
Could we get a DeLorean? So funny. Amy improvises. Jaws. They swim in the ocean and they terrorize the whole community. And then at the same time, like this sort of group mind, they both start going, Dunder, Dunder. No.
我们能弄来一辆德罗宁时光机吗？太搞笑了。艾米即兴发挥。《大白鲨》。他们在海洋里游泳，恐吓整个社区。然后与此同时，就像某种集体无意识一样，他们两个开始说：“邓德，邓德。不。
Dunder. Dunder. That's all improvised. And then they both start cracking up at nine minutes, 44 seconds. Go to that time code. The two of them are laughing. And I think it's because they're just cracking up like they're just having a good time. Wow.
邓德。邓德。”那全都是即兴发挥。然后他们在9分44秒时都笑喷了。跳到那个时间码。他们两个在笑。我想这是因为他们真的笑得很开心，就像他们只是在玩得很开心一样。哇。
I think they're both genuinely tickled that they came up with the Dunder Dunder in the moment. It's brilliant. It's brilliant. And then they go back on script at the very end when Holly's like, we haven't found our great idea yet, and Michael says, but we're circling it. Wow. Mm-hmm.
我想他们俩是真的觉得自己在当下想出“邓德·邓德”这个梗非常逗。这太绝了。这太绝了。然后当霍莉说“我们还没找到好点子呢”，迈克尔说“但我们正在接近它了”，他们在最后又回到了剧本。哇。嗯哼。
Wow. That was an improv in the middle of a scene. Yeah. Usually our improvs happened at the end. Yeah. And Ken and Paul and Jen said that the two of them were just magic together. You just see it. You really do.
哇。那是场景中间的一段即兴发挥。是的。通常我们的即兴表演都发生在大结局。是的。肯、保罗和简说，他们两个在一起简直就是绝配。你能看出来的。真的能看出。
Lady, should we go back to the volleyball game? It's getting heated. Pam scores another point. They're going to move on to the finals. Phyllis is like over it. Yeah, she twists her ankle. And then trots over to Bob Vance. Yeah, she has no problem running over.
大姐，我们要不要回到排球比赛？气氛越来越白热化了。帕姆又得一分。他们要晋级决赛了。菲莉丝一副受够了的样子。是的，她扭伤了脚踝。然后小跑着去找鲍勃·万斯。是的，她跑过去毫无压力。
And then there's classic Vacation Stanley, where he's like, you just had to be part of the group. And he's got his cocktail and his hat. I'm telling you, this is setting up Florida Stanley. Oh, you're so right about that. Well, now we need a replacement for Phyllis. And Rolf is going to call up Meredith, even though Angela volunteers. Rolf is so intense.
接着是经典的度假斯坦利，他说：“你非得凑进这个群体里不可。”他手里拿着鸡尾酒，戴着帽子。我跟你说，这简直是在为佛罗里达斯坦利做铺垫。哦，你这话太对了。好吧，现在我们需要给菲莉丝找个替补，罗尔夫打电话叫来了梅雷迪思，尽管安吉拉自告奋勇。罗尔夫太强硬了。
Yeah, Rolf says he didn't hear Angela volunteer because he doesn't hear cheaters, tramps, or women who break my friend's heart. And then there's this look between Dwight and Angela. I have two little tidbits to share about this scene. Number one, OK, so you know the part where I bump the ball? Yeah. OK, that was not a CGI ball. That was me.
是的，罗尔夫说他没听到安吉拉自告奋勇，因为他听不见作弊者、荡妇或者伤害他朋友心脏的女性的声音。接着德怀特和安吉拉之间有了这样一个眼神交流。关于这个场景，我有两个小花絮要分享。第一，好吧，你知道我把球撞过去的那个部分吗？是的。好吧，那不是CGI特效球。那是我。
That was real. And then when Phyllis is running to the sidelines, I spotted a man in a Yankees baseball hat. We took all of the trouble to put the whole cast in plain hats. And then they just let a guy sit in the front row with a Yankees hat on. What is that? What is that? It's just a lot of people. Someone's going to fall through the cracks.
那是真的。然后当菲莉丝朝场边跑去时，我发现了一个戴着纽约扬基队棒球帽的男人。我们费了那么大劲让整个演员阵容都戴着素色帽子。结果他们却让一个家伙坐在第一排，还戴着扬基队的帽子。那是什么情况？那是什么情况？这只是因为人太多了。总会有漏网之鱼的。
You know what they would usually do if someone showed up with a hat or something with a logo on it, they would have tape in different colors and they would just tape over it. Oh, yeah. Someone did not tape over a Yankees guy. Or maybe they did and he ripped it off. Scandalous. Scandalous. Oh, my gosh.
你知道如果有人戴着帽子或带有标志的东西出现，他们通常会怎么做吗？他们会用不同颜色的胶带把标志贴起来。哦，对。居然没有人用胶带把扬基队那个家伙的标志贴上。或者也许他们贴了，但他把它给撕掉了。太令人发指了。太令人发指了。哦，天哪。
We just had a dunder moment. We did. We had a group mind dunder dunder on Scandalous. Well, Jim is going to score a point and some trash talking starts. David Wallace says, we're still going to crush you, though. Charles is like, yeah, we are. Rolf comes out of nowhere. Oh, my gosh.
我们刚才又来了一次“邓德”时刻。确实。我们在“令人发指”这个词上也来了一次集体无意识的邓德。好吧，吉姆要得一分了，一些垃圾话也开始了。大卫·华莱士说：“不过我们还是会碾压你们的。”查尔斯说：“没错，我们会赢的。”罗尔夫突然从不知什么地方冒了出来。哦，天哪。
We could not get through this. Yes. We were all cracking up. He said, you suckers are going down. They're going to wipe their asses with your serves and piss all over your faces. Every time he said piss all over your faces, we would lose it. Yeah. And Reina's Dwight had to be like, whoa, whoa, whoa, come on, come on.
我们简直无法顺利拍完这段。是的。我们全都笑喷了。他说：“你们这些笨蛋死定了。他们会用你们的发球擦屁股，然后在你们脸上撒尿。”每次他说“在你们脸上撒尿”时，我们就会彻底笑崩。是的。雷纳饰演的德怀特不得不说：“哦，哦，哦，拜托，拜托。”
But we kept laughing. Well, now we're going to go to this little tidbit, the HR folks, and I love it so much, lady. John Hartman is back as corporate HR Kendall. Toby is wearing his logo hat, and they are discussing the HR convention last year. I could have watched the two of them talk for 20 minutes. Ken shared that Greg had this idea that David Wallace would hate Kendall the same way Michael hates Toby.
但我们一直在笑。好吧，现在我们要来看看这个小花絮，人力资源部门的人，我太喜欢了，大姐。约翰·哈特曼作为公司人事部门的肯德尔回归了。托比戴着他的标志帽，他们在讨论去年的HR大会。我能看这俩人聊上20分钟。肯分享说，格里格有一个想法，那就是大卫·华莱士讨厌肯德尔的程度，应该和迈克尔讨厌托比一样。
Oh, my gosh, it's so funny. Well listen, one more point, and Scranton is going to move on to play corporate, and Jim makes it. I mean, Dwight hugs Jim. Yeah. They're so excited. I know. Oscars like settle down, guys.
哦，天哪，太搞笑了。好吧，听着，再得一分，斯克兰顿就要晋级去和总公司对抗了，吉姆进球了。我是说，德怀特拥抱了吉姆。是的。他们太兴奋了。我知道。奥斯卡就像是在说，大家冷静点。
Relax, fellas. Jenna, Scranton was so good. Is that your memory that you guys were good at playing volleyball? I guess that's my memory. That Scranton, Dunder Mifflin was good. That we were good. That's your memory. Yeah.
放松点，伙计们。詹娜，斯克兰顿队太棒了。这是你的记忆吗，你们过去很擅长打排球？我猜那是我的记忆。斯克兰顿，邓德米夫林打得很好。我们打得很好。那是你的记忆。对啊。
Like, are you saying in real life? Yeah. Like, fictionally, and in real life. Yeah. Why? Because. Why are you smiling? Because.
等等，你是在说现实生活中吗？对啊。就好像，在虚构中，也在现实生活中。对啊。为什么？因为。你为什么在笑？因为。
I feel like this is a trap. Because that is not how Ken or Paul remembered it, and Ken talked about a lot of the ways the volleyball scenes were logistically difficult, and one of them was because you guys were all terrible. What? And they all three talk about it on the DVD commentary. Can we hear that? Volleyball is hard to direct, especially with people who don't have a clue how to play.
我觉得这是一个陷阱。因为这根本不是肯或保罗记忆中的那样，肯谈到排球场景在后勤上有很多困难，其中一个原因就是你们所有人都太烂了。什么？他们在DVD评论音轨里三个人都谈到了这一点。我们能听听那个吗？排球很难导演，特别是对于那些根本不知道怎么玩的人来说。
Oh my God, I couldn't believe it. They were terrible, I will say. Every other team that was playing against them, so much better. I don't know why our people were not good volleyball players. I was editing, Paul and I were alternating days on the set, and Paul was like, it's going really well, but our team is terrible. I don't know what to do, and I was like, well, maybe the other teams can be made to be worse. I know there was one point where I said, I think Scranton was playing Nashua, maybe
哦，天哪，我简直不敢相信。他们太烂了，我得这么说。所有跟他们对打的其他队伍，都好太多了。我不知道为什么我们的人不是优秀的排球运动员。我在剪辑，我和保罗在片场轮流排班，保罗说：“进展得很顺利，但是我们的队伍太烂了。我不知道该怎么办，”然后我说：“嗯，也许可以让其他队伍表现得更烂一点。”我知道有一次我说，我觉得斯克兰顿在跟纳舒厄打，也许是
Utica. And I just said, well, let's just play for a while. Let's just play some volleyball as we get warmed up. And Utica killed us, and I could tell looking at our cast, they all looked so sad. This is a terrible idea, let's just go back to the scene. Oh my God, you guys were the worst. The worst group there. Hey, to be fair, the other teams were filled with special business actors, okay?
尤蒂卡。然后我就说：“好吧，我们先打一会儿吧。我们热身时打打排球吧。”结果尤蒂卡把我们给秒杀，我看得出来我们的演员们看起来都太难过了。这真是一个糟糕的主意，我们还是回片场拍戏吧。哦，天哪，你们这群人简直是最烂的。所有人里面最烂的。嘿，平心而论，其他队伍里都是些专业的商业演员，好吗？
So after I listened to the DVD commentary, I thought, oh, I've got to watch Scranton and Utica play. Ken said that Utica crushed you guys. So I went back and watched the episode, and I never saw you guys play Utica. It's in the deleted scenes. Oh, wow. Yeah. And it features some major trash talking Andy.
所以在听了DVD评论音轨后，我想，哦，我得看看斯克兰顿和尤蒂卡对打。肯说尤蒂卡把你们给碾压了。所以我回去看了这一集，但我从来没看到你们和尤蒂卡打过。这在被删减的镜头里。哦，哇。是的。里面有一些安迪大放厥词的精彩片段。
Send it back. Yeah. Send that ball back. Don't mess with Scranton. No. Uh-huh. Utica. More like you sucks to cuff.
把球传回来。是的。把那个球传回来。别惹斯克兰顿。不。呃-huh。尤蒂卡。不如叫你真逊卡。
Who sucks to cuff? You sucks to cuff. Who sucks to cuff? You sucks to cuff. Who sucks to cuff? You sucks to cuff. Ow. Ow.
谁真逊卡？你真逊卡。谁真逊卡？你真逊卡。谁真逊卡？你真逊卡。哎哟。哎哟。
Sorry. Jim comes up to Andy and Dwight, and he's like pinching their arms so they stop. But yeah, Andy starts this whole chant about you sucks to cuff. Oh, my gosh. But in reality, they were crushing us. Yeah. Oh, I love that. Don't mess with Scranton.
抱歉。吉姆走到安迪和德怀特面前，捏住他们的胳膊让他们停下来。但是，是的，安迪开始了一整段关于“你真逊卡”的口号。哦，天哪。但现实中，他们把我们给碾压了。是的。哦，我太喜欢这个了。别惹斯克兰顿。
That made me laugh so hard. It's time for Michael and Holly's presentation. Oh, gosh. This is when David says, I have not seen this. He announces that they're going to sing a song, and they're like, no, no, no, it's a sketch. It's going to be like, David, you should already be worried. Yeah.
这把我笑得前仰后合。轮到迈克尔和霍莉的演讲了。哦，天哪。这时大卫说：“我还没看过这个。”他宣布他们要唱首歌，而他们说：“不，不，不，这是一个小品。”这就好像是，大卫，你其实已经该开始担心了。是的。
And then they say introducing Slumdunder Mifflinair. So Slumdog Millionaire was a hit movie that came out in 2008. According to IMDB, and this is a very brief synopsis, this is what it says, a Mumbai teenager reflects on his life after being accused of cheating on the Indian version of who wants to be a millionaire. Oh, I saw this movie, it was fantastic. Oh, it's so good. It's so good.
然后他们说，隆重推出《贫民窟邓德米夫林富翁》。所以《贫民窟的百万富翁》是2008年上映的一部热门电影。根据IMDB的资料，这是一个非常简短的剧情简介，上面写着：一个孟买少年在被指控在印度版《谁想成为百万富翁》中作弊后，反思了自己的生活。哦，我看过这部电影，太棒了。哦，太棒了。太棒了。
Everyone was talking about it. Yes. It was huge, just a great film. It won a gazillion of awards, including the Academy Award for Best Picture in 2009. But of all the movies to parody, to tell the story of Robert Dunder and Robert Mifflin coming together, no one knows what they're doing. Well, they're also going to get some facts wrong. One catch from KCK in Orlando, Florida, in Michael and Holly's sketch, they say that
每个人都在谈论它。是的。它太火了，真是一部伟大的电影。它赢得了无数奖项，包括2009年的奥斯卡最佳影片奖。但在所有的恶搞电影中，为了讲述罗伯特·邓德和罗伯特·米夫林走到一起的故事，结果没有人知道自己在干什么。好吧，他们还把一些事实搞错了。佛罗里达州奥兰多的KCK捕捉到一个细节，在迈克尔和霍莉的小品中，他们说
Dunder and Mifflin met in college. At Dartmouth, which incidentally is where Mindy went. But in Dunder Mifflin Infinity, Robert Mifflin said he knew Dunder through the Rotary Club. So I caught it too. Yeah. Ken shared that they really just drove home with the crowd watching to please not react in any way. Even the children don't crack a smile, nothing.
邓德和米夫林是在大学相识的。在达特茅斯学院，顺便说一句，这也是明迪去过的地方。但在《邓德米夫林无限公司》中，罗伯特·米夫林说他通过扶轮社认识了邓德。所以我也注意到了这一点。是的。肯分享说，他们真的开车回家时一路上看着观众，千叮咛万嘱咐请大家千万不要做出任何反应。连孩子们都不许露出一丝微笑，什么表情都没有。
And Ken was so happy with how the scene turned out because everyone really just looks at them so deadpan. And Ken said that Steve and Amy pulled him aside after the first take and they were like, this feels really uncomfortable. This is like so awkward. Amy was like, I'm rattled by it because it truly felt like they were bombing on stage in front of everyone. Well, I guess this sketch took like hours to shoot.
而且肯对这个场景的最终呈现效果非常满意，因为每个人看着他们的表情真的都毫无波澜。肯还说，斯蒂夫和艾米在拍完第一条后把他拉到一边，他们说：“这感觉真的好不舒服。这太尴尬了。”艾米说：“我被它搞得有点心神不宁，因为这感觉真像是他们在所有人面前演砸了。”好吧，我猜这个小品拍了好几个小时。
And in addition to being told not to laugh, the extras were not allowed to move from their spots for continuity reasons. So we would bring waters around and things like that, but they had to stay right there. And Jenny Tan had this tidbit in her breakdown from her visit. Andy Buckley, who plays David Wallace, would get on the little stage during the breaks and he would entertain the crowd with stories and jokes. She said he even sang a song, but he was like the entertainment. And she said it was just like the sweetest, most thoughtful thing.
除了被告知不准笑之外，出于连贯性的考虑，群演们也不被允许离开他们各自的位置。所以我们会把水什么的送到周围，但他们必须一直待在原地。詹妮·谭在她的探班幕后文章中也有这样一个花絮。扮演大卫·华莱士的安迪·巴克利会在休息时走到小舞台上，用故事和笑话来娱乐大众。她说他甚至还唱了一首歌，他简直就像是现场的娱乐担当。她说这真的是最贴心、最周到的举动。
And you know what? That is Andy Buckley right there. I was like, of course he did that. Of course. That is so sweet. Yeah. Well, the only person that's enjoying this is Stanley. We have some classic vacation Stanley when he has his cocktail and he says, I usually
你知道吗？那绝对就是安迪·巴克利本人。我当时就想：他当然会这么做。当然会。太贴心了。是的。好吧，唯一一个乐在其中的人是斯坦利。我们有一些经典的度假斯坦利镜头，他拿着鸡尾酒说：“我通常
don't enjoy the theater, but this is delightful. I think he's had a few cocktails by this point. I guess he has. There's a lot of booze being offered at this event. Now Michael and Holly are going to do something. They're going to announce that the Buffalo branch is closing and then they take a bow. This is news to the Buffalo branch. They are ticked off.
不喜欢看戏，但这太令人愉快了。”我想他此时已经喝了好几杯鸡尾酒了。我猜是的。在这个活动上有提供大量的酒。现在迈克尔和霍莉要做点事情了。他们要宣布布法罗分公司要关闭了，然后他们鞠躬致谢。这对布法罗分公司来说是个大新闻。他们气炸了。
Well, there are two especially very angry Buffalo branch employees. They were played by Brian Stack and Marla Garland. Brian Stack was a writer on Conan and I've known Marla for years. She is just delightful. Well, also seated in the front row, who's very upset about this branch closing is Jenny Tan. Yes. And she revealed that she was in the front row with a real life husband and wife couple,
好吧，有两个特别生气的布法罗分公司员工。他们由布赖恩·斯塔克和玛拉·加兰饰演。布赖恩·斯塔克是柯南秀的编剧，我认识玛拉很多年了。她真是个可爱的人。好吧，同样坐在第一排、对分公司关闭感到非常生气的还有詹妮·谭。是的。她透露说，她当时和现实生活中的夫妻档
Dan and Aaron, who were booked together to play extras on this episode. They gave them two fake babies and it's really great. You can see Dan sitting next to Jenny. And when Brian Stack as the angry Buffalo man is yelling, he's shushing his baby. He's like, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, don't let the angry man upset you, baby. Yes, exactly, exactly. David Wallace is furious. This is not how he wanted the Buffalo branch to find out.
丹和亚伦坐在第一排，他们是一起被预订来这一集演群演的。剧组给了他们两个假婴儿，这真的太棒了。你可以看到丹坐在詹妮旁边。当布赖恩·斯塔克饰演的生气的布法罗男人在大喊大叫时，他在轻声哄着他的婴儿嘘嘘。他一直在说：“嘘，嘘，嘘，嘘，别让生气的男人吓到你，宝贝。”是的，没错，没错。大卫·华莱士气急败坏。这不是他希望布法罗分公司得知这个消息的方式。
No. But one little boy just asked him if daddy will have his job at Christmas. And Michael's like, well, he's just thinking about his own gifts. Not helping Michael. The Scranton group huddles up. They're over by the picnic tables. And Meredith is like, I think we should forfeit the game out of respect. And Dwight says, people need volleyball now more than ever.
没有。但一个小男孩刚刚问他，爸爸在圣诞节时会不会失业。而迈克尔却说，好吧，他只是在考虑他自己的礼物。一点也没帮到迈克尔。斯克兰顿的小团队聚在一起开会。他们在野餐桌旁。梅雷迪思说：“我觉得为了以示尊重，我们应该弃权不玩了。”德怀特说：“人们现在比以往任何时候都更需要排球。”
Oscar agrees with Dwight. Now they have this rallying call. They want to kick corporate's ass. Yeah. And they're doing great. Petty Jim, which we get a little bit of. Petty Charles. Yes.
奥斯卡同意德怀特的看法。现在他们有了这个振奋人心的口号。他们想狠狠踢总公司的屁股。是的。而且他们打得很好。小心眼的吉姆，我们稍微看到了一点。小心眼的查尔斯。是的。
Petty Charles. Thank you. Petty Charles says, look who just woke up. And then scores a point and says, I've been up for a while. Okay. So now Dwight is going to stand up to Rolf. He is. And Jenna, I had one of those moments where I think I thought I heard something that's
小心眼的查尔斯。谢谢。小心眼的查尔斯说：“看看谁刚睡醒。”然后得了一分并说：“我早就醒了。”好吧。现在德怀特要挺身而出对抗罗尔夫了。他确实这么做了。詹娜，我经历了一个时刻，我觉得我好像听到了一个
not in the script. It's not in the subtitles. And I need you to tell me what I heard. What? Yeah. Okay. Kevin says it's six to six. It's a nail biter.
剧本里没有的词。字幕里也没有。我需要你告诉我我到底听到了什么。什么？好吧。凯文说比分是六比六。真是扣人心弦。
Angela says, Kevin, no, it's seven six or is that too much accounting for you? Rolf says, here's an accounting question for you. What does one fiance plus one lover equal? Answer one horror. Dwight says, okay, knock it off Rolf. Rolf says, what? She's sitting here casting aspirations and Dwight goes, Rolford, please Jenna, I swear I hear Dwight say Rolford, please.
安吉拉说：“凯文，不，比分是七比六，还是这对你来说算数太多了？”罗尔夫说：“我来问你个会计问题。一个未婚夫加上一个情夫等于什么？答案是一个恐怖。”德怀特说：“好了，适可而止吧，罗尔夫。”罗尔夫说：“什么？她坐在这儿冷嘲热讽的。”德怀特说：“罗尔夫，求你了。”詹娜，我发誓我听到德怀特说“罗尔夫，求你了”。
You mean like Rolford is Rolf's full name? Yes. It's not documented anywhere. I'm probably just losing it. I need you to hear it. I'm going to play it. Ready? Okay.
你的意思是“罗尔夫”是罗尔夫的全名？是的。没有任何地方记录过这个。我可能只是疯了。我需要你也听听看。我要播放了。准备好了吗？好的。
Okay. Knock it off Rolf. She's sitting there casting aspirations. Rolford, please. I am asking nicely. Oh. Okay. Rolford, please.
好吧。适可而止吧，罗尔夫。她坐在这儿冷嘲热讽的。罗尔夫，求你了。我是客客气气在请求。哦。好吧。罗尔夫，求你了。
I'm telling you. Okay. Here's the first thing I need to know is this. Is Rolf a name? That I don't know. Did we make that up or is it a name? Is Rolf short for Rolford? Well, there's a restaurant in Manhattan called Rolf's.
我跟你说。好吧。我首先需要知道的是这个。罗尔夫是个名字吗？这个我不知道。这是我们编造出来的，还是它本来就是一个名字？罗尔夫（Rolf）是罗尔夫（Rolford）的简称吗？嗯，曼哈顿有一家餐厅叫罗尔夫餐厅。
It's in Gramercy Park. Oh, here we go. Wikipedia. Rolf. It is a male given name and surname. It originates in the Germanic name Hrolf. Interesting. But now Rolford, Rolford.
它在格拉梅西公园。哦，我们开始吧。维基百科。罗尔夫。这是一个男性名和姓氏。它起源于日耳曼语名字Hrolf。有趣。但是现在，罗尔夫（Rolford），罗尔夫（Rolford）。
We need background music for ladies who Google like Jeopardy. We really do. Booty, booty. Okay. Let me tell you, there is the Rolford Leather Company in the UK. They are a supplier of fine quality leathers. Also just from Ancestry.com, Michigan had the highest population of Rolford families in 1880.
我们需要为像“爱八卦的女士们”这样进行谷歌搜索的人配点背景音乐，比如《危险边缘》的音乐。真的需要。动次打次。好吧。让我告诉你，英国有一家罗尔夫皮革公司。他们是优质皮革的供应商。另外，根据Ancestry.com的数据，1880年密歇根州拥有最高人口比例的罗尔夫（Rolford）家族。
So I think you might be right. Both names seem to be names. I mean, just come on. Okay. Knock it off, Rolf. She's sitting there casting aspirations. Rolford, please. I think you're right.
所以我觉得你可能是对的。这两个名字似乎都是名字。我是说，真是够了。好吧。适可而止吧，罗尔夫。她坐在这儿冷嘲热讽的。罗尔夫，求你了。我觉得你是对的。
I think we have broken a big case here. Mom Detectives, we declare Rolford. Put it on your calendar that this is the first time Rolford is being documented? Yes. In the office canon. Angela. I'm clapping for myself. I'm clapping for myself.
我觉得我们在这里侦破了一个大案。妈妈侦探们，我们宣布“罗尔夫”这个名字存在。把它记在日历上，这是第一次记录下“罗尔夫”这个全名吗？是的。在办公室正史里。安吉拉。我在为自己鼓掌。我在为自己鼓掌。
Applause for you. Thank you. Good work. Thank you. And now whoever does subtitles, change it to Rolford. Thank you very much. I'd like to say that that was a combo mom detective to ladies who Google move. Do you see how both of those came together?
为你鼓掌。谢谢。干得好。谢谢。现在无论谁做字幕，把它改成罗尔夫。非常感谢。我想说这真是一个“妈妈侦探”结合“爱八卦的女士们”的绝妙举动。你看到这两者是如何融为一体的吗？
It's beautiful really. In that moment. I'm proud of us. Ken shared that he really liked seeing Dwight softening to Angela. Angela's clearly moved by this and then right after the scene there would have been an Angela talking head. It got deleted but I wanted you to hear it. Today for the first time in months Dwight nodded at me and I have to admit it made my
真的很美妙。在那一刻。我为我们感到骄傲。肯分享说，他真的很喜欢看到德怀特对安吉拉态度变软。安吉拉显然被感动了，然后紧接着这个场景本该有一段安吉拉的单人访谈。它被删掉了，但我希望你听听看。今天，几个月来德怀特第一次对我点头了，我不得不承认，这让我的
heart set up just a little straighter than it's here. I know I seem hard and cold on the outside but on the inside I'm as warm as porcelain. I'm sorry for gushing on like this. Just must be the apple juice talking or I don't. It's very sweet. She is as soft as porcelain on the inside. Apple juice is not on the drink menu. I knew you were going to say that.
心在椅子里坐得更直了一点点。我知道我在外表上看起来坚强冷酷，但在内心深处，我和瓷器一样温润。我很抱歉像这样滔滔不绝。一定是因为苹果汁在作祟，或者我不知道。这太甜了。她内心和瓷器一样温柔。苹果汁根本不在饮料菜单上。我就知道你要这么说。
I also now like this expression of saying it just made my heart set up a little straighter in its chair. I loved that too. I thought it was cute. The game is going and Pam is going to fall. Lady, I did my own falling stunt. That's all me. I believed it.
我现在也很喜欢这种表达，说什么“这让我的心在椅子里坐得更直了一点点”。我也觉得这个很可爱。比赛正在进行，帕姆要摔倒了。大姐，我完成了我自己的摔倒特技。全是我自己演的。我相信。
I'm very proud of it. It's not the first time you fall in this episode. You fall twice. I do. Yeah. You had a spontaneous fall while you were playing fake volleyball earlier in the episode. Oh. I clocked it.
我为此感到非常骄傲。这并不是你在这一集中第一次摔倒。你摔倒了两次。我摔过。是的。你在本集前面打假排球时就曾不经意地摔倒过。哦。我注意到了。
You went down to your knees to get a ball. Huh. I'm a pro. You are sporty, Pam. Well, there had been a lot of discussion about using my double and shooting the fall from behind, but Ken said to sell it, they really needed to see my face on camera. And it wasn't the shoulder rotation. Yes.
你为了接球双膝跪地。哼。我是个专业人士。你很有运动细胞，帕姆。嗯，关于是否使用我的替身并从背面拍摄摔倒镜头，曾有过很多讨论，但肯说为了演得逼真，他们真的需要在镜头前看到我的脸。而且这并不涉及肩膀旋转。是的。
There was no reason why they couldn't just have me fall. It was not going to affect my shoulder. Randy told me that sometimes in movies, they will use a stunt double from the front and then they do CGI face replacement. What? Yeah. Face off. Kind of like the movie magic version of face off.
没有理由他们不能直接让我摔倒。这不会影响我的肩膀。兰迪告诉我，有时在电影中，他们会从正面使用特技替身，然后他们会做CGI人脸替换。什么？是的。变脸。有点像电影魔术版的《变脸》。
He said we could not afford that. So there was no putting my face on her face. Okay. So you know at the end of this, when Pam is going to leave to get her ankle checked, Dwight has to start stalling for time. And the first thing he does is he like kicks the volleyball really far away. This reminded me of like the butthole kid growing up, like when you played kickball, who would have a tantrum and kick the ball real far and someone had to go get it.
他说我们承担不起那个费用。所以根本不可能把我的脸贴到她的脸上去。好吧。所以你知道在这个结束时，当帕姆要离开去检查她的脚踝时，德怀特不得不开始拖延时间。他做的第一件事就是把排球踢得远远的。这让我想起了我成长过程中那种像“屁眼小孩”一样的人，就像你玩踢球游戏时，总有人会发脾气把球踢得很远，然后得有人去把球捡回来。
Well we had a fan catch from Emily H in Ohio who said, I have a background catch at 16 minutes, 55 seconds. When Dwight kicks the volleyball away to stall the game, there are some weird face cutout board picture things in the background. And I think there is a person sticking their head through one of them. Really? I saw those things. They look like something from a carnival.
嗯，我们收到了来自俄亥俄州埃米莉·H的粉丝留言，她说：“我在16分55秒处发现了一个背景抓帮。当德怀特把排球踢开以拖延比赛时，背景里有一些奇怪的挖空脸部的人形立牌。而且我觉得有一个人正把头伸进其中一个里面。”真的吗？我看到那些东西了。它们看起来像狂欢节上的道具。
All right. I don't know if this is related, but Jenny Tan wrote this in her diary for the day. She said, during the first few takes of Dwight kicking the ball, there was a background performer hiding in the shack. And whenever the volleyball was kicked near it, this person would wave his arm outside the shack and ruin the take. She said needless to say, this person was asked to leave the set and was told not to return for the rest of the week.
好吧。我不知道这是否有关，但詹妮·谭在当天的日记中写下了这个。她说，在德怀特踢球的前几次拍摄中，有一个背景演员藏在小木屋里。每当排球被踢到附近时，这个人就会在小木屋外面挥舞他的手臂，把镜头给毁了。她说不用说，这个人被要求离开片场，并被告知这周剩下的时间都不准回来了。
I don't know. What's happening? I don't know. I was like, could that be the person whose face was in the little like picture thing? Well, you know, I'm going to go back and look. I know. Well, not in the shack waving their arms or Michael and Holly, how's that for a transition? That was a wonderful transition, I like that.
我不知道。发生什么了？我不知道。我当时想：那会不会就是那个脸在小图片板里的人？好吧，你知道，我要回去看看。我知道。好吧，不是在小木屋里挥舞手臂，而是迈克尔和霍莉，这个转场怎么样？那是个绝妙的转场，我喜欢。
We should share with you guys. We often wonder how to transition. We are trying so hard not to have every transition be lady. Lady are well. Yes. Oh, the wells. We do a lot of wells. Dr. Peter Thibodeau, please don't count the wells.
我们应该跟你们分享一下。我们经常琢磨该怎么转场。我们真的很努力不让每一个转场都变成“大姐”。大姐，好吧。是的。哦，“好吧”这个词。我们用了大量的“好吧”。彼得·蒂博多医生，请不要去数“好吧”的次数。
Oh, don't. Oh, I have Dr. Thibodeau a few times and it was staggering. Anyways, Michael and Holly are going to reflect on their skit and on their mistake of mentioning the buffalo thing. And they have this very sweet couplet of dialogue. Holly says, well, I'm glad we did it. Michael says me too. And there's a long pause and he says we have a lot of good material for next year's sketch.
哦，别数。哦，我数过蒂博多医生说了好几次，数量简直惊人。不管怎样，迈克尔和霍莉要反思他们的小品以及他们提到布法罗这件事的失误。他们有了一段非常甜蜜的对话。霍莉说：“好吧，我很高兴我们做了这件事。”迈克尔说：“我也是。”接着是一阵长长的沉默，他说：“我们为明年的小品准备了很多好素材。”
And she lights up and says, I can't wait. Well, this was a really beautiful performance by Stephen Amie. They shared in the DVD that everyone at Video Village where they were watching the playback was crying. They said, Jenny was there, Jenny Tan, she was crying. And then Kin said something I just loved about this scene between Stephen Amie. I wrote it down verbatim and I want to read it to you. Okay.
她眼睛一亮说：“我等不及了。”嗯，斯蒂夫和艾米的表演真的非常精彩。他们在DVD中分享说，在监视器前回看录像的录像村里的每个人都在哭。他们说，詹妮当时也在，詹妮·谭，她哭了。然后肯说了一句我特别喜欢的话，是关于斯蒂夫和艾米之间的这场戏的。我是逐字逐句记下来的，我想读给你们听。好吧。
Kin said, it's the toughest kind of scene because in a way everything is happening and nothing is happening all at once. There's a gigantic shift that takes place, but it's all under the surface and the challenge is to find it over and over again, take after take as if they've never been there. Yeah. I just thought that was really well said because every time they did it, they had to have that discovery of knowing that something just changed for both of them. It's a beautiful scene.
肯说：“这是最难的一种场景，因为在某种程度上，一切都在发生，而又什么都没有在发生。有一个巨大的转变正在发生，但它全都隐藏在水面之下，而挑战在于要在每一个镜头、每一次拍摄中一遍又一遍地找到它，就好像他们从来没有经历过一样。”是的。我只是觉得这话真的说得太好了，因为每次他们拍这段戏时，他们都必须体会到那种发现，意识到有些事情对他们两个来说刚刚发生了改变。这是一场美丽的戏。
And then they say goodbye. And then Michael has this fantastic talking head where he says he didn't find the perfect moment that day to share those things with her, but it's okay because they're going to be one of those couples who have a long story and he's just going to be patient. Yeah. Jen said in an interview that they loved setting up this idea that Michael was going to find a way at this picnic to try to make his move with Holly, but then over the course of the day, as he spent time with her, he was reminded that they have something really special and
然后他们道别了。接着迈克尔有一段精彩绝伦的访谈，他说他那天没有找到完美的时刻来和她分享那些事情，但没关系，因为他们会成为那种拥有漫长故事的情侣，而他会保持耐心。是的。简在一个采访中说，他们很喜欢这样一种设定：迈克尔本来要在这次野餐上找到方法试图对霍莉采取行动，但随后在这一天的相处中，随着他和她在一起，他想起了他们之间有一些真正特别的东西，
he gains this more mature way of looking at the relationship and it's very different than how he would behave if this were Jen or any other woman from his past. And that she said, quote, he was calm and confident and quieted by this thought. And I loved that. And this talking head right here is why you know this is his soup snake. Yeah. His soulmate. So cool.
他对这段关系的看法变得更加成熟，这与如果是简或他过去的任何其他女人时他的行为会有很大不同。她还说，原版引述：“他感到很平静、自信，被这个想法安抚了。”我太喜欢这个了。这里的这段单人访谈就是为什么你知道这就是他的“汤蛇”。是的。他的灵魂伴侣。太酷了。
100%, right? Yeah. Well, Jim is going to take Pam to a local hospital and for whatever reason, they have this belief that Dwight can stall this volleyball game. I mean, for how long have you ever gone to get an ankle checked or anything? Even just the commute and finding parking and getting inside and signing up and getting your insurance information and I don't know, Jim is feverishly filling out some hospital form while a sassy nurse is wheeling Pam away.
100%对吧？是的。好吧，吉姆要带帕姆去当地医院，不管出于什么原因，他们坚信德怀特能把这场排球比赛给拖延住。我是说，你去检查脚踝或者干别的什么事，花了多长时间？甚至仅仅是通勤、找停车位、走进大楼、挂号、填写保险信息等等，我不知道，吉姆正狂热地填写一张医院表格，而一个态度傲慢的护士正推着帕姆离开。
The sassy nurse was played by Allison Martin. She's done a ton of television comedy, most recently, Grace and Frankie. And she did an episode of Law and Order. We had a fan question from Christy H in Maryland who said, my 13-year-old son thinks the hospital that Jim and Pam go to is the Scrubs Hospital. Is he right? He's a huge office fan. And Sam Oh from Milwaukee, Wisconsin said, at the end of this episode, you guys are clearly
这个态度傲慢的护士由艾莉森·马丁饰演。她演过大量的电视喜剧，最近的是《格蕾丝与弗兰基》。她还演过一集《法律与秩序》。我们收到了来自马里兰州克里斯蒂·H的粉丝提问，她说：“我13岁的儿子认为吉姆和帕姆去的医院就是《实习医生风云》里的那家医院。他是对的吗？他是《办公室》的超级粉丝。”来自威斯康星州密尔沃基的萨姆·奥说：“在本集结束时，你们很明显
in the hospital from Scrubs. Do you remember anything about working there? Was the cast of the other show around at all? Well, I tell you what, Christy, your son is right. Sam, you are right. This was the hospital that they used on Scrubs. It is a former hospital. It's not even around anymore.
在《实习医生风云》里的那家医院里。你们还记得任何关于在那里工作的事吗？另一部剧的演员当时在附近吗？”嗯，我跟你说，克里斯蒂，你儿子猜对了。萨姆，你是对的。这就是他们在《实习医生风云》里用的那家医院。那是一家前医院。它甚至已经不在了。
They've torn it down. But at the time, it was an abandoned hospital. It was the Riverside Community Hospital in Sherman Oaks. The Scrubs cast were not there that day, but Randy told us that their production graciously allowed us to use some of their pre-dressed corridors and examination rooms. And something I'll tell you is that we shot all of this hospital stuff on Monday. It was our very first day of shooting. It was before we ever went out to the company picnic.
他们把它拆了。但在当时，它是一家废弃的医院。它是谢尔曼奥克斯的河滨社区医院。《实习医生风云》的演员那天不在那儿，但兰德尔告诉我们，他们的剧组非常友好地允许我们使用他们一些预先布景好的走廊和检查室。我要告诉你们的是，我们把所有这些医院的戏都在星期一拍完了。那是我们拍摄的第一天。那是在我们去公司野餐之前。
So all of that emotion was just day one. Day one. Wow. We started with the cold open, and then we relocated to the hospital. And Jenny recalled that she was not allowed to observe the hospital. She knew that we were going to a hospital, but she didn't know why. And we'll tell you more about that in just a little bit. I don't know how much longer Dwight can stall.
所以所有那些情绪全都是在第一天拍的。第一天。哇。我们从片头冷戏开始，然后转场去了医院。詹妮回忆说，她不被允许去医院现场观摩。她知道我们要去医院，但她不知道为什么。我们稍后会告诉你们更多关于这方面的细节。我不知道德怀特还能拖延多久。
The corporate team is insisting that Scranton put in their subs. And Dwight is doing this really long, roundabout thing of like, well, how many people must get hurt before a lesson is learned? One, two, three, four. He's doing a horrible job of stalling. But Jim is like, Dwight, keep stalling. And then he gets called into the room where Pam is. And they get some pretty big news.
公司团队坚持要求斯克兰顿换上替补队员。而德怀特正在兜着一个非常长的大圈子，说什么“在吸取教训之前，究竟有多少人必须受伤？一、二、三、四。”他拖延得糟糕透顶。但吉姆说：“德怀特，继续拖延。”然后他被叫进了帕姆所在的房间。他们得到了一个相当重大的消息。
But we can't hear it. Nope. But I think we know what it is. Yes. We got some mail. A lot of people wanted to know why was this scene silent? Obviously, they're being told that they're going to have a baby. Why couldn't we hear it?
但我们听不到。没有。但我想我们知道那是什么。是的。我们收到了邮件。很多人想知道为什么这个场景是无声的？很明显，他们被告知他们要有一个孩子了。为什么我们听不到？
Well, this was partially inspired by the British show. There is a scene in that series where Tim is going to tell Don how he feels about her. But first, he takes off his microphone. And Jen and Paul thought that this made that moment even more intimate. It's one of those things kind of like the teapot note. There's nothing that you could write that could ever meet people's expectations of what it needed to be. So if you leave it for people to fill in themselves, it'll always be the perfect note.
嗯，这部分灵感来自于英国原版剧集。该系列中有一个场景，蒂姆要告诉唐他对她的感觉。但首先，他取下了麦克风。简和保罗认为这让那一刻变得更加亲密。这就像茶杯纸条一样。没有什么你能写的东西能够达到人们对它应有样子的期望。所以如果你把它留给人们自己去填补想象，它永远都会是完美的纸条。
I agree. And I feel like Randall Einhorn shared with us that the further you were away from a moment, the more intimate it feels to watch. Yeah. And so removing the sound makes you pretty far away. Yeah. Well, this idea was something we had been toying with for a long time. On Casino Night, there was a whole conversation about whether or not we should hear Jim tell
我同意。我觉得兰德尔·艾因霍恩和我们分享过，你距离一个时刻越远，观看时就会感觉越亲密。是的。所以去掉声音会让你离得很远。是的。嗯，这个想法是我们一直在琢磨了很长时间的。在赌场之夜那一集，关于我们是否应该听到吉姆在停车场告诉
Pam that he has feelings for her out in the parking lot. We ultimately decided to keep the audio for that. But we're going to do this again when Pam says goodbye to Michael. Every once in a while, it was a trick we could use because we were a documentary. We could pull the sound and make a really impactful moment. So Jim is going to run into the hallway now. He's going to call Dwight and he's going to say, send in the subs. We got mail.
帕姆他对她有感觉，曾有过一整场讨论。我们最终决定保留那段音频。但当帕姆向迈克尔告别时，我们要再次使用这个手法。每隔一段时间，这是一个我们可以使用的技巧，因为我们是一部纪录片。我们可以抽掉声音，创造一个极具冲击力的时刻。所以吉姆现在要跑进走廊了。他要给德怀特打电话，说：“换上替补。我们有信了。”
NetE from Minnesota said, Jim's face when he finds out he's going to be a father gives me goosebumps every time he is acting goals in this scene. And Abby M from Utah said, what were the directions given to John for when he finds out about the baby? So yeah, John Krasinski, man, why he didn't win an Emmy? Why you didn't? Why the whole freaking cast didn't win more awards because the show is delivering right here.
来自明尼苏达州的NetE说：“吉姆得知自己要当父亲时的表情每次都让我起鸡皮疙瘩，他在这场戏里的演技简直是天花板。”犹他州的艾比M说：“对于得知孩子消息时的约翰，导演给出了什么样的指导？”所以，是的，约翰·卡拉辛斯基，天哪，他为什么没有赢得艾美奖？你为什么没有？为什么整个该死的演员阵容没有赢得更多的奖项，因为这部剧在这里表现得太出色了。
Ben shared on the DVD commentary a note that he gave John for this scene. And I thought it was great. And I want you guys to hear it. The one thing I told John to remember is that over the course of this series, he's developed a relationship with the documentary camera operator. And so when John emerges from the room to make the call to Dwight, something about seeing his pal, the cameraman, kind of suddenly got him very choked up. Wow, what a great note.
本在DVD评论音轨中分享了他为这场戏给约翰的一个指导意见。我觉得这太棒了，我想读给你们听。他对约翰说的一件事是要记住，在这部剧的拍摄过程中，他和纪录片摄像师之间已经建立了一种关系。所以当约翰从房间里走出来给德怀特打电话时，看到他的好朋友摄像师的某种举动，突然让他感到非常哽咽。哇，多么棒的一个指导意见！
Cool? Yeah, that, he had told me this look. Because we debated whether or not he should be so wrapped up in the moment that he should ignore the camera. But in fact, it was the opposite. This look right there. That look. It was almost like, you know, the cameraman has been sharing so much of what's going on
酷吧？是的，他曾跟我说过这个眼神。因为我们曾争论过他是否应该完全沉浸在当下而忽略摄像机。但事实上，恰恰相反。就在那里的那个眼神。那个眼神。这几乎就像是，你知道的，摄像师一直在分享那么多发生
with Jim that, you know, that it became very important to acknowledge him here. So the look he is talking about happens at 20 minutes, 50 seconds. And you guys know these moments in your life where you're feeling all of this emotion and then you see a good friend and it just comes pouring out of you. It's that person that says, are you okay when you're not okay? And I loved that. And I'm so glad that they had John as Jim look to camera and look to his friend. It's a brilliant note.
在吉姆身上的事情，你知道的，在这里向他致意变得非常重要。所以他谈到的那个眼神出现在20分50秒处。你们都知道生活中这样的时刻，当你感受到所有这些情绪时，然后你看到一个好朋友，它就从你体内汹涌而出了。就是那个人，在你过得不好时问你“你还好吗？”我太喜欢这个了。我很高兴他们让扮演吉姆的约翰看镜头并看着他的朋友。这是一个绝妙的指导。
That's great directing by Ken Quapas and a great performance by John. And you too. I loved this moment. Give me tear up again watching it. Well we got a fan question from Kaylee and Auburn, New York. Jenna, did you have any idea before this episode that the writers were going to make Pam pregnant? And what were your thoughts when you found out? Well, I barely knew.
这是肯·卡帕斯出色的导演功力和约翰精湛的表演。还有你也是。我太喜欢这一刻了。看它时又让我热泪盈眶了。好吧，我们收到了来自纽约州奥本的凯利的粉丝提问，詹娜，在这一集之前，你知不知道编剧要让帕姆怀孕？当你发现时，你的想法是什么？好吧，我几乎一无所知。
They did not warn us like weeks or months ahead. I found out basically right before the table read. And I remember sitting in that table read and Ken Quapas read the stage directions and there was like an audible gasp in the room. Everyone was like, so here is what the script said. This is what Ken read. The doctor tells Jim something and we see Jim's face light up. Pam is also grinning.
他们并没有提前几周或几个月警告我们。我基本上是在台词围读会前夕才发现的。我记得坐在那场围读会上，肯·卡帕斯读着舞台指示，房间里发出了倒吸一口凉气的声音。每个人都像是在说，所以剧本上是这样写的。这是肯读的内容：医生告诉吉姆一些事，我们看到吉姆的脸亮了起来。帕姆也在咧嘴笑。
Jim and Pam hug. Jim walks out with a big smile on his face. So the script did not even say that Jim and Pam were going to have a baby, but everybody knew, oh my gosh, Jim and Pam are going to have a baby. Yeah, that was just for the table read. If you read the shooting draft for this episode, those scenes are omitted. It just says scene 51, 52, 53, see production for details. Yeah, they immediately took it out of all documentation, all scripts, everything.
吉姆和帕姆拥抱。吉姆脸上带着灿烂的笑容走了出来。所以剧本甚至没有写吉姆和帕姆要生一个孩子，但每个人都知道，哦，天哪，吉姆和帕姆要生孩子了。是的，那只是为了围读会准备的。如果你阅读这一集的拍摄剧本，那些场景是被省略的。上面只写着：场景51、52、53，详情见制作部门。是的，他们立即把它从所有文件、所有剧本、所有东西中删除了。
It was a huge secret. Uh, yeah. They shared on the commentary that our producers made a huge effort to keep this a secret. They didn't want it to get out to the audience. They didn't want it to be ruined. They could not let NBC know. So crazy. So crazy.
这是一个巨大的秘密。呃，是的。他们在评论音轨中分享说，我们的制作人为了保守这个秘密付出了巨大的努力。他们不想让它泄露给观众。他们不想让它被剧透。他们甚至不能让NBC知道。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
So none of the scripts had the final scenes, just like you said, right? And then the scripts that went out, they were omitted from those. And then every day you guys, they would send NBC the CDs of the dailies of what we had shot that day. That's right. It was deleted from that. Oh my God. And then the final master cut of the whole episode that the network gets to review before
所以没有任何剧本包含最后的场景，就像你说的，对吧？然后发出去的剧本里把这些都删掉了。然后每天，伙计们，他们会把我们那天拍摄内容的日常样片光盘发送给NBC。没错。里面删掉了这一段。哦，天哪。然后整集在播出前供电视台审核的最终母版剪辑，
it goes on the air. They had deleted it from those as well. Oh my gosh. And then Jen said that all of the scripts, every single disc that was sent to NBC, they were all watermarked so that you couldn't copy them in any way. And Jen said in hindsight, if she was someone at NBC, she'd be like, they don't have her watermarker CDs or scripts. Like what's going on?
他们也从里面删掉了这一段。哦，天哪。然后简说，所有的剧本，发送给NBC的每一张光盘，都带有水印，这样你无法以任何方式复制它们。简在事后说，如果她是NBC的工作人员，她会想：“他们怎么连带水印的光盘或剧本都没有？”这到底是怎么回事？
Like what? What's all the hullabaloo with the watermarking? That is so crazy. She said in thinking about it, they watermarked scripts and CDs that didn't even have a scene to copy. It's so true. But they were just, I guess, so paranoid. Wow.
就像什么？加水印到底在搞什么鬼？这太疯狂了。她回想起来说，他们甚至给那些根本没有场景可复制的剧本和光盘都打了水印。确实如此。但他们大概是太偏执了。哇。
But it didn't get out there and it was a true surprise. It was. I guess when they finally had to, at the last minute, send the deliverable, airable version, they finally put the scene back in. That's right. But it was too late for anyone to ruin the surprise. Or to even make promos. I think that was always their big fear, was that in order to tease the audience that they
不过消息并没有泄露出去，这是一个真正的惊喜。确实是的。我猜当他们最后在最后一刻不得不发送可交付、可播出的版本时，他们终于把那个场景加了回去。没错。但那时候要破坏惊喜已经太迟了。甚至连做宣传片都来不及了。我想这一直是他们最大的担忧，为了勾起观众的好奇心，他们
would reveal big plot points. And Greg was always so protective of that. All it would have taken is one NBC teaser of you and Jim in a hospital. That's it. And they'd have an announcer being like, Jim and Pam, get the news of a lifetime on tonight's finale. Thursday, NBC. We got more mail about this scene and I'm just going to just run through them real quick.
会透露重大的剧情走向。格里格一直对此保护得很好。只需要NBC出一个关于你和吉姆在医院的预告片就够了。就这样。然后就会有一个播音员说：“吉姆和帕姆，今晚大结局迎来一生难忘的消息。周四，NBC。”我们收到了更多关于这个场景的邮件，我只想快速地过一遍。
Phoebe T from Indiana would like to know if I was actually pregnant or if it was just for the show. Phoebe, it was just for the show. I was not even married to Lee yet, though we were dating and we were getting a little serious, but we weren't at baby yet. No, you weren't there yet. No. You were still in what I call the sexy life.
来自印第安纳州的菲比·T想知道我当时是真的怀孕了，还是只是为了节目效果。菲比，那只是为了节目效果。我当时甚至还没和李结婚，虽然我们在约会，而且关系变得有点严肃，但我们还没到生孩子的阶段。不，你们还没到那一步。不。你还处于我称之为的性感生活阶段。
We were in sexy life and I will be wearing a fake belly in the upcoming season and I'll tell you all about it. And then Louise from Washington said, why did the writers decide on Pam and Jim having a baby before getting married? You guys, that's just Greg. He liked to keep people on their toes. He liked to surprise the audience. And finally, Liz B from Columbus, Ohio said, what ended up happening with Pam's ankle?
我们当时正处于性感生活阶段，我将在接下来的几季里戴着假肚子，我会把这一切都告诉你们。然后来自华盛顿的路易斯说，为什么编剧决定让帕姆和吉姆在结婚前生个孩子？伙计们，那只是格里格的风格。他喜欢让人们保持悬念。他喜欢给观众一个惊喜。最后，来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的莉兹·B说，帕姆的脚踝最后怎么样了？
Liz, I love you. I love that in this whole episode, we have left you hanging about Pam's ankle. I feel you. This is how I feel when I watch a John Wick movie. He has lots of injuries and I need those, I need them to be resolved. So Liz, it was just a slight sprain. It's just going to be a little rest, a little elevation, a little ice. She's going to be fine.
莉兹，我爱你。我喜欢在整整这一集里，我们一直让你悬心于帕姆的脚踝。我懂你。每当我观看一部《约翰·威克》电影时，我就是这种感觉。他受了很多伤，而我需要这些伤，我需要它们得到解决。所以莉兹，那只是轻微扭伤。只需要休息一下，稍微抬高，敷点冰块。她会没事的。
And that, my friends, was company picnic. I have one last thing to say. Is this goodbye to Charles Miner? I believe it is. Aw, Idris, you were fantastic. We really enjoyed rewatching all of your episodes. That's really fun. You were fun to work with.
朋友们，这就是公司野餐。我还有最后一件事要说。这是在跟查尔斯·迈纳说再见吗？我想是的。哦，伊德里斯，你太棒了。我们真的很享受重温你的所有剧集。真的很有趣。跟你合作很愉快。
You sure were. Happy company picnic day, everybody. And happy new year. Oh my gosh, that's right. This was a great way to kick off the new year, I think. It sure was. We will be back next week and we will be starting season six. We are now officially halfway through our rewatch.
你确实很棒。大家公司野餐日快乐。新年快乐。哦天哪，没错。我觉得这是开启新年的绝佳方式。确实如此。我们下周会回来，并开始第六季。我们现在正式完成了重温之旅的一半。
I can't believe it. I can't believe it. It's flown by. It is flown by. We hope you have a great week. We hope you have a little bit of vacation Stanley in your day and we'll be here next week. See you then.
我真不敢相信。我真不敢相信。时间过得太快了。时间真的过得飞快。希望你们度过愉快的一周。希望你们的生活中能有一点“斯坦利式的假期”，我们下周见。到时候见。
Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com for a free one-month
谢谢。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com，免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，使用优惠码 OFFICE。
trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。